so you can perfect
[Music]
all right welcome back guys this is the
dope as usual podcast
we are here to talk about life problems
accomplishments drugs
and everything in between i am your host
dopaziola thank you for joining us to
another episode
if you're on the road i know it's monday
morning if you're on the road good luck
at work i know monday [__] sucks
but thursday night's pretty damn dope so
that's the day to look forward to that's
what i used to do for school for work
just
try to imagine yourself after work and
it goes a lot faster
if you are watching us or listening to
us i'm at school
like i said if you're on your way to
work you're at school you're at home
with your homies
thank you for taking the time to come
support thank you for taking time to
listen
i want to get right into this i want to
get right into what has been on my brain
for the past week
we are obviously we're a couple episodes
ahead we uh we filmed about two weeks
out
that way we ne it takes a long time to
edit this [__] 4k what how long did it
take morning
seven hours somewhere around [__]
forever
yeah somewhere around forever it takes a
long ass time to edit this [__]
so we wanted to be a couple weeks ahead
so like i said uh it's been on my brain
since we dropped
guys uh let me just say this the weed
industry the weed world the world that
i've been in forever
you guys are so [__] supportive i
know this is not like a weed pot
this is not what this is about we're not
here what's your favorite train that's
not what we're doing here
but we do smoke weed i am involved with
weed
at all times so to see the community
transfer over from just
me [__] weeds smoking giant joints
transfer over to the podcast
you guys you guys really me and marty
were shocked
how [__] crazy was that when i called
you that first night like
we ranked on apple podcast guys in one
[__] day
right number 24 on comedy of the world
not just like oh these weed kids comedy
podcasts nah
out of all [__] comedy podcasts we
got ranked 24 and that's because of you
guys i mean
it probably dropped now but that first
night we just it was a boom
it really it's i'm just excited it's
it's like
when you finally realize that you're not
shitty at math like yo math class what's
when's the next [__] test that's how
i feel dude that's
that's exactly how i feel i feel hyped i
feel like we just won the first
basketball game and like the next game's
tomorrow
thank you guys i just wanted to start
off by saying that because
it made my [__] day it truly makes my
day knowing i got so many people in my
own family like yo
listen to the podcast i'm shocked on how
good it was like yo
think first off you're a dick shocked
but second thank you so much for
supporting thank you for going out of
your way to listen my uncle ron dude
my uncle ron i haven't seen in a long
time he's pretty offensive
he called i didn't tell you he called me
the day i haven't talked to him since i
was 6 17. i don't really talk to him
that much we never really got along
he called me the other day and said hey
i went on your website and i go
[__] here comes i went on your website
and you know what
i know thomas i'm impressed i'm
impressed and i almost forgot you're not
a little child anymore and i'm hearing
[__]
and weed i forget that you're not a kid
like you uncle ron
it's been [__] 14 years [__] but
he said i've never had
dope explained to me so so well you're
like a news anchor and
all the things he's saying like yo
that's all i wanted to hear from you
guys thank you for
taking the time to go you're smoking
weed no you're not smoking weed you're
having fun
that's exactly what i'd wanted to hear
and that was refreshing that was really
cool
that's just something that's came over
this past week thank you guys thank you
for the support on that first episode if
you haven't watched it
dope as usual podcast is on youtube
every
all these camera setups everything
you're hearing if you're on spotify or
apple or google
yes there is visuals to this we're doing
it in 4k
we're trying to make it as as dope as
possible the background is looking bomb
me and marty have fixed this sign five
damn times we are obviously not handymen
we cannot hang an led strip to save our
[__] life until today
today work perfect it's up there it's
it's up there and it's not falling all
right
um so thank you guys thank you for that
support for that boost that first
episode's popping
if you have not seen it the josh wolfe
episode just aired
josh wolf's funny as [__] please go
watch that [__] he ha
he's just he's the guy you want to be in
your family and you meet
you know what i'm saying like you go i
can't wait for thanksgiving [__]
cousin josh is going to be that's
the coolest coolest uncle josh wolfe is
so [__] funny dude
so it really made me happy to know
that's the first guest also
if you haven't seen it on youtube dope
as usual clip dope as usual podcast
clips
that's a clips channel for everyone that
doesn't have an hour or two hours to go
watch the whole video
you can go watch the clips the
highlights either way even if you're
just here commenting if you're just
listening you don't ever
comment you don't ever that's fine thank
you for supporting thanks for taking
your
the time out of your day to click our
[__] and listen thank you so much
with that being said i'm going to get
into this joint right here but i'm going
to say
a little warning marty do you want a
joint i'm good
you sure i haven't actually i have
extras right here i'm going to be
hacking all over the microphone
all right all right so guys i want to
say this right now
my tolerance is just dog [__] i i
i'm not gonna say what guessed it was
but we filmed a guest last week it'll be
coming out in two weeks
filmed a guest last week i have a sinus
infection right now
i just started an all juice diet i tried
to do it for a week
and i smoked like four or five grams on
this lap
last podcast i got so light-headed and
so
high and just space out i felt like i
was in high school again
so rule of the podcast from here on out
i'm not gonna smoke seven grams just
back to back to back
anymore i'm gonna pace myself i might
let this [__] go out and relight
it we'll see
so that's my new thing not getting so
damn high on this podcast because it
really
it really threw me off i had a bunch of
notes last week and i just
they were non-existent so let's get into
my very very very first
piece that i want to talk about today
marty have you ever had braces have you
ever had to do the dentist [__]
no no you said that [__] [__] you
were like
because i was bragging to my daughter
just had to get them basically and i'm
bringing
or you were talking [__] i'm like i'm
the only one in here never had braces
what are you just going to tell me
see you're talking [__] yeah
no i had a big ass gap in my teeth
though so i got that bonded without
braces
oh wow that was cool i didn't know that
was real um the reason i bring that up
is
i've never had braces i've never had uh
anything i'm
really lucky to have straight ass
perfect ass teeth i'm not saying like oh
your teeth are that [__]
i'm just saying if you want to be
technical my teeth are completely
straight
like everything's identical i'm lucky
because a lot of my family members have
had braces
but the unlucky thing guys and i'm going
to tell you this if you are driving in a
car
please pay attention to the road this is
about to get real descriptive
all right that's my number one thing if
you're listening to us in the car please
pay attention because i don't want the
last thing you hear is
and this [__] i don't want the
some high-ass [__] screaming
into the mic all right
so i'm gonna tell you guys what happened
to me um
since i was a kid i've been grinding my
teeth not not like a tweaker
i'm not a method just grinding it to
grind i grind my teeth in my sleep it's
completely nocturnal i have no control
i used to blame it on lucid dreams like
oh i have really cool dreams i could do
whatever i want
the consequence is i grind my [__]
teeth because my dreams are so cool
there has to be a downfall and it's my
teeth so i've been grinding my teeth my
whole life you could hear that [__] when
i was sleeping my grandma my mom used to
wake me up stop it
like what the [__] do you think i'm
gonna do tell myself hey when you're
in that involuntary [__] stop that [__]
so
what happened guys i grabbed my teeth my
whole life then i started doing a little
bit of cocaine when i got older
got worse i think it got worse so i went
to a bunch of different dentists because
my
my teeth hurt guys i'd wake up with like
sawdust
i can go like this like that and there'd
be like grimy pieces of sand that's my
teeth party that is a nightmare to me
that i bit through
mouth guards straight through them went
to the dentist to get bite guards made
it through them they said i've never
done double and i did double that bit
through that [__] in two nights
didn't triple never bit through it again
so it's involuntary i'm sitting there
grinding my teeth
the reason i bring this up i go to a
bunch of different dentists last year
and they keep uh suggesting invisalign
and i'm in my head thinking
you [__] burglar you're just trying
to take money from me i don't need
invisalign [__] my teeth are
straight
i don't need it after the third dentist
i went to i realized
well maybe they're not all lying because
all of them said the exact same [__]
so apparently invisalign can fix your
bite it can fix your back teeth
it can also make you stop grinding so
guys
last last january i started my
invisalign treatment right
one thing they don't tell you
they may or may not have to shave your
teeth yes
shave your teeth with metal
all right i already don't like needles
we'll get into that whole doctor's
office
dilemma saga maybe another day but
i'm a grown-up all right i'm a grown-up
i went in there and i almost screamed
and walked
i was so upset marty i remember you
remember
you remember okay you guys ready for
this this is what happened to me this
barbaric ass [__] so like i said if you
are driving please pay attention the
road
just listen you went in there to like
pick up i went in the description
i had my friend in town right he was in
town waiting in the car with rosie i
said
wait right here i'll be right back i
text them 20 minutes later and say i
don't know they got me sitting down in a
chair
you guys drive around and get something
to eat or something so 10 minutes goes
by
20 minutes goes by i hate any kind of
dentist i hate anything that might have
a needle
i hate all things
there i am the dentist assistant comes
in
with a [__] tim the tool man taylor
saw like
straight up tim allen walked in with
this an automatic toothbrush with
a swivel on the end but like a band saw
you know what i mean like a circular saw
but it was only like this big like a
size of a 50 cent piece and i went
what is that for first thing i said
what's that for and he goes oh it's for
your teeth i go what do you mean
what do you mean it's for my teeth
you're gonna put that on my teeth like
yeah we gotta shave your teeth and i go
stop
can you go get the dentist and i she
came in and i argued with this woman for
48 minutes straight
about how you never told me that i had
to shave my teeth to put on a mouth
guard and she said
well you were talking about the moon and
the stars with my assistant
when they gave me my consultation the
assistant was very cool we started
talking about cool [__]
he never mentioned that you're gonna
shave my teeth so there we go finally i
really paid all the money and they said
well this is how it works
do you want to do it and go [__] let's
do it
so guys there i am imagine me [__]
one year ago not a little kid
imagine me one year ago just [__]
[__] just [__] sick
i'm just cursing everything like
thinking even if it doesn't hurt i'm
pissed
so what it is is a super super thin
piece of metal
they do this for all you watching on
youtube
they want to shave the gaps in between
your teeth even if there is no gap
they're gonna make a gap does that make
sense
if you're in between two teeth they
shave the edge of both of those teeth
to make giant gaps so when the
invisalign starts pushing your teeth
together they don't crush
makes perfect sense i really really feel
bad for the first person that had to
figure that out
so there i am sitting there
so i'm just looking at this thing coming
to my mouth like oh my god oh my god i'm
just
gripping my seat just [__] heated
that i'm in this situation i was just
gonna go smoke weed with my friend
all i was gonna do is pass by grab it
and then we're gonna go to melrose and
smoke weed
i had a really fun day playing with my
friend
so you didn't have face surgery i had no
surgery in mind dude
i i'm there this man goes calm down
calm down and i'm like you calm down
[__] i told him what do you mean calm
down man this is
foreign to me you want some tequila i
have it in my backpack i looked at him
like are you serious no i don't but i do
have tequila and i went i don't want
this doctor's office anymore this
[__] drinking on the break
i can't do this good thing it was in the
morning he puts this damn drill in my
mouth
and starts sawing in between my teeth
and i can feel it it doesn't hurt
that much it's just in my mouth and i
could smell it
you know when uh shit's really grinding
fast and it just smells like burnt hair
i could smell it so strong in my face
and this
soot and you can see dust and i'm
sitting there just trying
i'm holding my lip like this so he
doesn't cut my lip
i remember guys i'm [__] high all i
did was thought i was picking up my i
thought i was picking up trays
and i'm a hypochondriac when it comes to
the doctor but what do you mean no you
hit my bone
you hit my nerves like i was scared so
there is
and also here's a hero and uh oh no
that's all i hear like whoa what and i
tell him the reason i told her i want to
shave my teeth like yo i'm on camera
you want to cut my teeth i can't can't
happen
do something else and they said there is
nothing else so i had to do it
so there it goes oh no
his machine the blade broke it broke in
half
bent he's like i've never seen that
happen before let me go get another
blade
15 minutes later he comes back so we
don't have any other blades
and the dentist is within the head lady
she comes in i tell her well then we'll
just stop right she goes we can't stop
we can't we have to do it because if not
your teeth are going to smash together
and i'm looking at her and she said the
only alternative is manually do it and i
go what do you mean
manually do it so i have a little saw
and i go wait stop you want to get a
handsaw and saw my teeth off
and she said yeah
so there it is man this guy has assault
probably this big
holds the end of a saw two or three inch
saw a very skinny one you know like
the old uh the old lumberjacks where one
guy's 30 feet away this guy's 30 feet
away and they're pulling together
marty on like that big long saw that's
what it was but like this
so he puts one half in half
out on my teeth and starts going and it
it this hurts and he says all right i'm
gonna get to the gum and i go stop stop
what do you mean you're gonna get to the
gum he goes i have to go straight down
into the gum because the teeth
grow into the gum so you have to get
about a quarter centimeter into the gum
for it to stay straight
and i say you're gonna have to slice my
gum through he goes it doesn't hurt as
much as you think
and i'm looking at i'm like oh you
[__]
today's not the day i'm sweating i'm
pouring sweat
i am scared as [__] he gets to my gum
it hurts just as bad as you would think
he's sawing into your gum
he said it hurts not as bad everything
he's saying is
dog [__] he went to [__] san joaquin
valley college from merced to get that
damn degree
because i got some tequila now i gotta
cut your gums
that's my day so far and he's letting
you know as it's happening he's letting
me know gonna hit the gum
so guys he has to do one six two three
four
four five spaces he has to saw through
one no you got one and a half with the
machine the rest was manual
so as he's doing it i'm bleeding he's
doing the machine that sucks the blood
out of your mouth
so i know some shit's going down right
so my teeth are sawed
i took a picture after i called my mom i
was so upset like mom look at my teeth
she goes what the [__] happened
guys i had gaps in my teeth like a
little kids when they're just getting
their teeth in
i just like that i had gaps in my
[__] cheese
bro it was so nasty well no not like
that like that
the the picture go up with your cursor
no down
to the right right there that's what my
teeth look like in the middle they are
all spaced gapped even though they were
all touching
i had that smile when i've had a perfect
smile my whole life
you know how [__] upset i was i got
invisalign to fix my bite
and here they are over there [__] up
my front teeth so
that was my experience at the dentist
and then i went to the store lemonade
next door and drank lemonade
oh god it hurt i don't know why i didn't
think not to not drink [__]
lemonade right after my open wounds
but that was a year ago guys then covet
happened two months later
delayed my [__] three weeks and then
another three weeks another three weeks
so i'm
i'm about two and a half months behind
but the reason i brought this up because
my [__] invisalign just staring at
that [__] i have to use it every day
very annoying but it's way better than
braces rosie's had braces for five years
her doctor whole ordeal but her doctor
basically robbed us
we had to go to the bet as better
business bureau and they're refunding us
dude
every dollar we spent on her braces and
this is this we're the 60th
case against that dentist merced come on
you're the white doctor in the nice part
of town you're not supposed to be
scamming [__] man that's why i
didn't go to eighth street doctor
that's a bug for 15 copay like
damn it's cheap out here come on the
grill
yeah remember those you guys know those
mexican kids with the grills but they're
unintentional
you ever see wait wait do you have a lot
of mexicans in buffalo
exactly zero
i have never seen a mexican person so i
moved here
exactly now we have puerto ricans
oh no sorry
okay exactly zero so the reason i said
it have you ever seen a
little latin kid marty with a full
silver grill
no i'm it's not coming to mind it's like
the guy jaws
from uh from double 07.
the all metal teeth little mexican kids
have gold and silver
all caps it's amazing it looks great it
looks awesome to me
because they all look like southern
wrappers and i think they all got kodak
black with those teeth
the all capped teeth i love that [__]
anyway
that's when you know you're not taking
care of your kid when you're eight or
four-year-old has all silver teeth um
but that wasn't me man i took care of my
teeth until this [__] sawed them
so yeah there we go and a little update
i'm barely into this joint i'm proud of
myself
you're still dealing with this
invisalign [__] though right like i just
got a new set of trays
i just got a new set um
i went december 19th and uh december
22nd is when i got sick as [__] remember
i got the [__]
heavy ass sickness so they got me sick
too
i got sick and all that [__] happened
i'm pretty sure we recorded a video like
the next day the next day and i felt
like
dog [__] remember i don't know my head
hurts felt terrible and then all this
[__] happened
but yeah guys that was a invisalign
that's my invisalign story
and did it work though i mean is there
any upside i have not grinded my teeth
in about six months
i'm gonna be honest i haven't grinded my
teeth at all it totally
worked totally [__] worked but i hate
which is worse though the grinding
because i wake up with sore
teeth like my whole imagine all the
spaces in your mouth
soar and there's like a little like
grind of sand in your teeth
it's it's disgusting it's not fun not
fun at all
but uh yeah it's all it worked yeah all
right it worked
so on to another little thing i saw i
watched tv the other day for the first
time a long time i just watched netflix
and
[__] movies in the office so i
watched cable television the other day
i don't remember what i was watching i
saw some commercials
have you seen commercials in the past 20
years they're stupid
all right i saw this commercial or
herpetitis hepatitis hepa this take this
side effects are you know
death uh your [__] rip open stupid
[__] the side effects are always worse
than the thing obviously we've all heard
that before
here here's some new [__] guys i saw
this and had to stop what i was doing
talk to my girlfriend stop what you're
doing and look this
commercial came out it's just a bunch of
random people just
you know smiling smiling smiling and
then the [__] text comes in
for what it is it's called discove
ready for this it's called the scovie
you know what this pill does guys
it lowers your risk for getting hiv
process that think it over say it out
loud to yourself
process your lowers yep pretty stupid
this pill lowers your risk for hiv
lowers it doesn't stop
it doesn't stop the risk
so they're saying it's like yo this
cotton shirt is less flammable will it
still catch on fire oh for sure
but not as fast as the other cotton it's
the dumbest [__] i've ever [__] heard
basic condoms do that too all right i'm
just gonna say that condoms do that also
not having sex with aid filled people
helps i know it's not always a choice
but yeah guys there's a pill now not a
pill to help with your hiv regulation
it's a pill that slowers your chances
i want to know i want to know in that
science lab
what science lab they're all sitting
around a table like yo we you know we
fixed hair loss and ed
and all this stuff you know what about a
pill hear me out
what about a pill that lowers your risk
for getting aids
the other three guys go that's [__]
stupid no hear me out
what if it lowered it what if it lowered
it by a little bit
can you imagine this conversation of
somebody having to barter
and and just and just compromise well
what if we made it lower 40
well you still get aids do you
understand the stupidity of this entire
commercial is just it's like we're
living in an idiocracy
idiocy [__]
yeah like air is still a thing
like i'm thinking like aids maybe they
don't want to cure it there's more
they don't want to cure they want to
they want to charge you for it yeah but
is there enough people actively getting
aids i'd be trying to come up with the
40 percent cure bro there's
countries getting aids all right all
right i'm ignorant
i like you i'm ignorant you looked the
other side of the warehouse yeah you
weren't even looking my way i'm sure i'm
ignorant
yeah bro people like that people still
get aids man
a hundred percent marty um who's the
last celebrity we heard of getting aids
charlie sheen like five years ago all
right you got it that's true
age is real it's real but uh yeah i just
thought it was unfucking believable i
saw the commercial and i just
i have to talk about it because i
thought it was ridiculous something
even more ridiculous than i saw on tv
are you ready
marty i don't think you saw this because
you're you're a responsible adult
and you don't watch tv you have kids and
jobs so
the other night when i was watching tv i
saw a commercial come on
for earth for humans this [__] was meant
to be out there
they made the commercial and went host
that [__]
ready it just starts off guys it's just
i know you've seen this if some of you
have seen this you're going i know
right if some of you seen this it starts
off in space
and has like an astronaut going by and
it's a nasa
commercial are you ready for this
when the [__] have you ever seen a nasa
commercial right
so they're telling you all this cool
space [__] yep that's it right there
telling you all this cool space [__]
right and then it says civilian flight
here's your chance to go to space
what the [__] yo nasty's hurting for
money bro
i'm trying to i was just waiting for
this song they're
hurting they want they're giving john
and jill's [__] 40 bands
they're taking flights to space this is
the first
all-civilian flight to space first off
all civilian who the [__] flying that
[__]
i know they might have a pilot but they
should say they shouldn't say all
civilian trip to space because that just
sounds like death
yeah but yes guys nasa put out a
commercial
a real commercial saying here's your
chance no information
no information no price no nothing just
did didn't the nsync or backstreet boys
try to go to space a while back guys
somebody in the uh correct me if i'm
wrong i'm pretty sure it was lance
bass from nsync right a blonde dude
he was going to space and at the end it
was too much money but he already put a
deposit down
yeah google it i'm a [__] idiot you
have the power of the internet at your
fingers
please google that yep that's that's the
one
officially kicked off oh he got kicked
off
what did he his dance moves must have
been too hard
for that flight because how do you kick
off lance bass but you know what
ah we got too many people on let's kick
off lance pass
he's so random we're backstreet boys we
need to actually better you
know iglesias wanted to come on
yo kid rock is actually flying why do we
keep talking i love kid rock
not just music i just love kid rock as a
person but the they didn't hear that
though that was the
patreon only rant oh that's right oh
another thing dope as usual on patreon
we have a bunch of
behind the scenes we have a bunch of
ridiculous things on there if you want
to go sign up we got a nickel bag
for five dollars we got a dime bag for
ten dollars a month
excuse me so we let the cameras run for
the first 15 minutes of the josh wolfe
episode
we're talking about random [__] i just
love joe dirt so much i think is why i
like kid rock
don't tell joe i found his parents
i love that [__] movie but yeah guys
nasa's over there [__] up just
panhandling
that's what i see that as can you got
any change
that's what nasa's doing we need all
your savings accounts guys
because we are [__] up i don't know
man they make how much is their budget
billions maybe trillions of dollars i
have no idea don't quote me on this
but they need pocket money right now
they truly do marty
and also are you going to space if you
have the opportunity
do i need to answer that [__] no okay
there you go on an airplane
that's exactly i knew that was gonna say
[__] all that noise i ain't going to
space i've seen
rocket man i've seen an armageddon
there's nothing good for me out there
can i stand
oh i can't stand up well that's what
humans do
i don't know if i can just stay the ship
floating through nothing
i'm good space it's too high for me
anyway
just watch one strange rock that's like
the most amazing series of all time it's
on nothing that's a crack that's a crack
documentary what are you talking about
that's about crack cocaine
yeah it does sound like a crack epidemic
yeah but no that's the way they filmed
it the way they did
everything to it just had me staring
drooling that like kids need to watch
that
[__] for school and planet earth planet
earth is like this my cousin william he
uh
he showed me that planet earth is wild
as hell if you're just
on oxies and you're sitting there planet
earth is pretty entertaining
other than that you're just like yo
landscape's great can we just fast
forward you've got to do it you've got
to be a videographer like god damn look
at the polka and the compression
yeah i don't even know what i thought
boca burgers and veggie burgers i was
like what do you mean
the [__] you talking i'm mad ignorant oh
there's photographers
[Music]
can you set the settings for me on the
camera all right roll it go
that's me man i'm sorry but i got [__]
to do i can't learn the cameras and plus
i can't even do long division because
there's too many steps they ever tell
you my long division horror story
i i don't think so you guys ready this
is completely off topic i know we're
just ranting at this point
so i won math student of the year in
seventh grade at tanaya
i really good at math until
you introduce x's and some dumb
quadratic formula
[__] so what happened to me guys
this is why i'm so good at you've seen
me do math in my head like malcolm in
the middle
i can do crazy ass math in my head when
it involves drugs i don't know why
when it involves pounds i can go yeah so
you're gonna make this this
like the office how many is that in pies
kevin
8 thousand pies that's me but with weed
third grade no second grade we're no
third grade we weren't i'm at chee
elementary and merced
we're learning long division right long
division you know the
[__] little vans symbol
you know what i mean long or yeah that's
long division so you don't even know
anyway you put your numbers on top of
remainder this are that [__] this
divided by i don't know the steps
anyway i was sick i missed school
i don't know what day it was i missed
school i come back we're on day two
of long division i miss day one
obviously
that's the most crucial part of long
division if you don't know about
math the beginning is usually mad
important
so so as a kid i'm not going to stand i
was i don't want to be embarrassed
people always made fun of me as a kid
already
so i wasn't going to go yo teacher i
have no idea what the [__] you're
talking about i wasn't going to say
anything so i
shut up and did this one you guys know
if you guys ever been in school before
you've done this before
where you're pretending to do your work
and you're just looking at everyone
else's paper like
yo i have no idea how you got there what
the [__] and then you just stop
and that's where and that's where
[__] lifelong cashiers are formed
because that's me but i was like
high school was just a blur it's a third
grade marty
okay all right high school damn
i'm going back really the whole i just
remember being half asleep through the
whole thing
always i haven't seen him yet about
recess
what do you mean canceled recess with
middle school you know what i mean
it's called lunch bro you still still
play yeah well not when it's uh
a goddamn blizzard uh oh yeah that's
right that's right that's right
that sucks that sucks man um
oh [__] was oh long division so day two
i'm just sitting there going i don't
know what to do i turned my paper in and
just said see me
i told my teacher i missed day one well
you need to do the tutoring after school
and i went oh okay for sure
i'm not gonna go to that [__] you
want me to add extra time in school
you might as well ask me to do push-ups
continuously because i ain't doing none
of that [__] [__] you
so there i am winging it all right
i'm winging it guys i'm doing long
division and i'm doing division and
times and all this [__] long ways
like the tree here's a
300 here's a tree 3 30 and 10 and this
and that breaks down to this that's how
i got my fractions
that's how i did it my whole life all
right i won master of the year not
knowing how to long divide
my work was this big on my paper because
i'm doing five and five and five and
i would write it out so that's how i i
that's i don't know how long divide
that's my story how i'm dumb and i still
manage to win that [__]
without knowing how to do any of it i'm
just really good at math in my head
because i have to sit there in class i'm
like all right doing your hand by five
oh let's say 85 all right
so that's that's exactly how i learned
how to do math that's it
i have there's no anything else that
story i don't know how he even got on
that [__] story
but that's me man i [__] hated school
so damn much
excuse i [__] hate this school so
much guys um
but good thing you know all that long
division now right bust that out all the
time i don't know how to loan divide
still
or no i never learned or was it all for
nothing
i didn't learn do you think the end of
that story
that's my point all that for i mean [__]
you get to tell the story on the podcast
but
all those years of like you're so dumb
i'm in class
one day i'm gonna talk about this on the
podcast for seven minutes and
it'll all be worth it i remember one
time i cheated on my test
and i remember thinking don't cheat bro
you're better than i thought
then again i'm trying to get into that
university and i started cheating
just think back on it when i'm [__]
in university and like thank god and
that's how i
that's how i coped with being a cheating
[__] in this in the eighth grade
in new york they had this thing that
they held over your head called the
regents diploma the whole time the whole
time you're in school the regents
diploma this this extra diploma all this
[__]
then you graduate what does that mean
nobody even ever brought it up once in
life
what does it mean some bonus diploma i
don't know oh nobody gets [__] nobody
even brought up the diploma afterwards
like
man you can work at mcdonald's did you
fill out this application like i did
well on all of it just kidding here's an
apron that's pretty much how you get a
job i got my
job at mcdonald's [__] face drunk
17. i was no 18.
i was [__] up i was with my friend
joan anthony this guy
steve steve is a guy that was about 10
years older than this i sold him weed
so i sold him weed we hung out with him
he bought us beer
right he was like 31. i didn't realize
the first uh
piece of [__] i ever met i didn't know
he was a piece of [__] uh
not to us not as a outward as a piece of
[__] but
under wraps like he was living with this
this girl she was a nurse
she had a bomb house steve didn't have a
job steve had a really nice car
because this girl bought him all the
[__] for his car do you see where i'm
going with this
uh every time she left the room and go
[__] god i can't stand her
that's what he would do i feel so
[__] bad because she's hanging out
with us
even though we're younger she's like all
your homies blah blah she'd leave the
garage eyes were all smoking as soon as
she
love you close the door oh my god this
[__] [__]
dude she was so nice she was the lady
with live
laugh love things all over her wall
she's that lady right
and he's talking about those other girls
he's with and i'm sitting there as an 18
year old like
oh you're a piece of [__] i don't i
don't think i'm now charging you more
money
i was thinking of all the like i don't
really like you anymore steve
and i was at steve's house
and with anthony and joe we're drinking
coronas
wild day i don't never drink corona
we're drinking coronas i'm like seven
deep i'm pretty [__] up i drove there
so i know i have to wait
at least two or three hours then drive
because i don't like drinking and
driving immediately
it's just not worth the risk so i'm
sitting there it's like 3
15. we we ditched [__] college we did
not go to school that day
we're at steve's i get a call i'm like
what number is this
i sell weed i'm gonna answer every
[__] call it might be
yo my phone died i need eight pounds
like thank god i picked up this random
number
so there i am picked up the number hello
who's this
i answered it like normal and oh hello
it's so and so we're uh from mcdonald's
i'm looking at your application and i'm
telling everybody
oh yes hello the customer service voice
pops in oh hello yeah i put the
application last week
oh hello thank you so much and the lady
says i do have an opening
if you can get in here for an interview
you're pretty much the only person i'm
going to be interviewing today
and i told her oh you want it today it's
15-ish remember that and i said oh you
wanted it today she said
if you can be here by 3 30 3 45 that
would be great because i have somebody
else coming in
but for a different position but i also
don't want to
she basically said she was cool she was
basically like get your [__] ass down
here before i hire somebody else without
saying
i'm going to hire somebody else if you
don't get that's exactly what she told
me and i said
no no worries whatsoever i can be there
right now just give me about 20 minutes
she said perfect
and i said which mcdonald's is this at
obviously it's the farthest [__] one
away from where i'm at
i'm at steve's we're on 24th street and
like
s yeah like 24th and s street in merced
which is on one side of town the other
side of town mcdonald's right across the
street from basically golden valley high
school
um oh yeah 24th street on s and s street
and merced yeah and on the other side
the whole other side of town
so i look at everybody and go guys they
want me to go for an interview and they
go [__] yeah
right now but right now and i asked
steve do you have any mints
he gave me he gave me let me use
listerine he gave me some gum
i got in my car and went oh if you crash
today while you're drinking your word
dumb [__]
guys i went 75 down the residential
i knew i had to be there at a certain
time or she was just gonna look at me
like
oh he wasn't serious you know even
though she only gave me 24
[__] minutes lead time still i went
down the street got to 99 freeway
i got to the 99 freeway in like eight
seconds i got on the freeway and i got
to
i got to that mcdonald's from steve's
house in like eight and a half minutes
if you know him or said i was smashing
i pulled up still [__] up i wasn't
shitfaced blurry i was just
i shouldn't have been driving i'm
sitting there thinking
all right remember when you shake her
hand put your like lean back a little
bit stand tall
breathe to the left you know don't
breathe directly at her because i'm a
little child
obviously i'm 18. i can't even [__]
drink and i'm coming to smell like beer
drive i drove to my so much it's too
much right
so my customer service voice just
[__] kicked in hello
uh i let you know oh and my uncle john
my uncle john had already been working
there before
and she mentioned she's do you know
anybody that works at mcdonald's or
anything i said my uncle john john what
john john strange
she goes oh john i know john i actually
hired him like oh wow no way
and i just pulled this [__] got the job
right then and there i started the next
morning
as i'm leaving i'm thinking well so can
i get drunk and come to work because
that [__] had no [__] idea that i
was slightly [__] up
so i drove back to steve's 45 minutes
later
and got drunk the rest of the day and
had a job
how [__] fun how did we get on that
topic
oh ged having mcdonald's that's how i
got hired at mcdonald's guys
and also i quit mcdonald's the same
mcdonald's that not that one i
transferred to the r street by my house
i quit that mcdonald's twice while on
shift and i'm the guy flipping the meat
with the burgers on the grill
i just stormed out twice both times
nobody noticed or gave a [__] because i
was the only one there didn't speak
spanish
except for the guy the the manager is a
white dude i
left in the middle of my shift [__]
flipper
on on the stove thing topper
meat still going dropped my apron with
my name tag took my hand off and walked
right the [__] out
first time i remember i was i saw this
girl jackie maramontes remember her
rosie
i saw jackie miramontes i'm scraping the
meat if you don't if you never worked at
mcdonald's and if you do
i'll get ready oh get ready you know the
meat you have to
it's a big grill and you have to press
down the top and it grills on both sides
so you don't really have to flip it by
the scraper flipper looking thing you
scrape all the gunk off right
so it sounds like the everlasting
gobstopper
machine when it's stopping goes
it sounds just like it the first time i
was in the building went
willy wonka look at this is great all
right cool so
it's like my fourth week at that one i'm
just scraping the meat juice into the
tray
all the gunk and then i'm putting new
burgers down and i'm just
pouring sweat i have long hair i have it
like done back
and it was then the opening of the
remodeled that's a
whack mercedes we had an opening and a
lot of people showed up
for the remodeled mcdonald's
not even oh it's our first one
[__] it's the fourth one
and it was their our street it was
remodeled to that i walked out of that
door right there marty
pissed that exact door twice
[__] thought of my [__] drove
straight to ramone's house and got
[__] up and played blitz and played
this game
so they didn't hold on did they fight
when you say it twice okay i'm i'm
not done all right so jackie maramontes
everybody's there the
everybody's uh at the everybody's at the
opening
and they're coming in 29 cent
cheeseburgers remember we were kids it
used to be 29
wednesdays 39 whatever days they did
that as the opening
right [__] really showed up
there was 100 people outside
so i look up i'm scraping the meat and i
just feel like a piece of [__] i'm
sweating i can see the glare off my arm
you know that glare of sweat i'm just ah
it stinks the mcdonald's meat before
it's cooked smells just like dog food
just like dog food so like the like the
dry dog food so that's not
a plus so i'm scraping it i look over i
see jackie this is
remember i just graduated high school i
look over i see her and she's super cool
i smile
hi and she smiles oh hi and i go to
scrape it and my hat like
moves or something my hair like falls in
my face sticks to my face while i'm
sweaty
and i'm scraping the me and i go to move
my [__] hair
and my hands greasy so i wipe grease all
over my eyebrow
and i remember thinking like i got so
frustrated at the fact that i felt gross
i'm looking at jackie like i just
graduated i'm like
this is not where i need to be i don't
like this job
jackie's here eating not working the
[__] stove and remember the reason
i'm so upset
nobody talks to me i'm the only one that
does not speak spanish everyone on the
[__] shift
every shift i ever went to they all
looked they all gave me the [__]
cancun thing
oh you don't speak spanish
[Music]
same [__] thing every time so i'm
sitting there oh hello
no straight i'm telling you these these
ladies would not even acknowledge i was
there
it was kind of [__] up so i'm there
and i look at the sky through the roof
of mcdonald's and i'm like
looking just this is not for me this is
not where i need to be
i just did this not even threw my hat
down you know when you just grab your
hat
lifts off your head and drop it i went
dropped my hat and it
fell i took my apron off i untied it
dropped it right where i was standing
and i walked
right the [__] out took the corner took
the left and walked right out the
building no clock out no nothing didn't
say and
a word to anybody got right into my
[__] dodge intrepid my green dodge
and trevor
drove the five blocks to ramones like i
said played nfl blitz
did the lighter game like this in the
garage who can get it the highest and
land on your hand
for like eight hours did nothing
productive should have just stayed at
work
i quit the next morning my because i
said i have a second job i had a second
job at a
you know the boxed wine yeah i used to
do that [__] i used to make the [__]
packages that boxes the wine
hated it next morning i lost my job
after i quit mcdonald's job i go [__] i
got another job the next morning i had a
day off
for the box wine job they called me and
said it was a temp job
they called me you're like yeah we're
not going to no no longer need your
services go back to
whatever lady you did you know they say
your name and say get another job
basically
and i'm right in front of my grandpa my
grandpa tom's on 6th street i'm looking
at my phone like oh my [__] god
and that's when i realized i gotta go
back to mcdonald's
it's like it's like it's like you cut
someone off a traffic hey
[__] you and then you guys pull up to
the same house for the party
like that's how i felt like oh no this
is gonna be
bad that's how i felt dude so
uh i had two days off mcdonald's after
that next day so i quit mcdonald's
the next day i lose my job i had the day
off anyway for the other for mcdonald's
and that job but they quit they called
me to let me know they let me go
the next day i had no mcdonald's shift
so two days in between and then i had
the next day to work right
so i just walked into work guys cause
you know mcdonald's gives you a plethora
of [__] hats and
aprons so i walked into work marty
like nothing happened like that episode
of seinfeld when he tells his boss
you're an [__] public restroom all
that one i walked back into
work and i just went back on my shift
and no one said
[__] no one said a thing guys like no
one said
a word to me and i just it's doing the
meat scraping
putting them in the what were you gonna
say if they did say something
like oh i was gonna [__] my pants so i
had to run out and there's somebody in
the bathroom so i had to go home right
then and there and i got sick i had to
go to the doctor i got food poisoning
that's exactly what i was gonna say
because it's very reasonable oh you're
not gonna come and tell me you're gonna
[__] between your pants
just get out of here that's like i had
to take a [__] so i dropped my stuff i
don't wanna [__] on everything
i was gonna go all in i was gonna go all
in
so nobody said a word nobody said a word
to me
i worked for like three more days and i
did it again
i came into work at like four o'clock
for my shift and it said it's
hot it was summer it was summer oh right
before i was like august september
because i just started college
so it was hot i was
irritated as [__] i left ramones in the
middle
of a [__] uh blitz game like blit
we're playing on nintendo 64 blitz
super smack brothers and we was like
four of us there so you know
right after high school you don't want
to do [__] you're done you don't got to
go to school but i'm in college i have
to go to co
i needed to go but all my homies they
they had jobs they had to be at work
that day
so imagine you know that feeling of i'm
the only one that's gotta
oh my [__] god that's how i felt
i left like i'll see you guys on my
lunch break
you guys know that feeling of hey guys
i'll be back for my lunch break let's
smoke
that is the best feeling ever is when
you're pulling up to the house but the
worst feeling is when
16 minutes when you have to leave just
to make it back i hate that [__]
so i told him i'll see you guys in my
lunch [__]
go to work walk in remember it's hot
same thing i'm about there for like 45
minutes
i don't see anybody i know but i'm just
seeing a line full of people you know
when you're when you're ordering or
somebody you're with is ordering a fast
food restaurant you're just looking at
the [__] making your food
that's all you do is look at him and go
oh yeah he makes a fast
oh well that person sucks oh that's why
my food sucks you do that you judge the
[__] out of everybody because it's
hilarious like
because i work there too oh this
motherfucker's on it
killing it you gonna be always make
comments to your head so i'm just
looking at the corner of my eye watching
people watch me
you know what i mean i hate that [__]
feeling i look over
scraping the meat it's hot as [__] i
open the thing hell esteem hits me so
you automatically get sweaty you stink
and i just i don't know what it was it
was it was the same feeling but like
expanded i was just what am i doing my
life
[__] business school this is some
[__] i'm gonna go work for [__]
i'm moving companies my family has
moving companies i'm just gonna go do
that
i'm gonna sell more weed i'm gonna do
something else because this is some
[__] i do not like doing it i just
don't like the meat
the meat section of mcdonald's it
[__] stinks put me anywhere else
i'll do whatever i just hate doing that
[__] but that's like the grunt work so i
you know i'm the only one that speaks
spanish so when they're like hey who
wants to work
with me and everybody says not me it's
spanish i go what did he say
they're like well he used to walk on the
[__]
so that's how that happened and
same thing this time i got i was pissed
i grabbed my hat i
threw that [__] on the ground i took
off my apron i [__] threw it and i
walked down and gone
god i yelled like in my sec i'm done
i walked out i left again no one said a
thing
no one said nothing no one said [__] no
one came after me no
please get your stuff clock out i didn't
do [__] guys i walked straight out
i don't even know how i got on this
[__] top oh yeah gds
so i walked out i was just heated i was
just
really really really mad and i went home
i didn't go to ramones i didn't go back
i went home my grandpa was at work
and i just sat there like all right i
need a job because i'm not going to work
at mcdonald's
anymore then i walked to ramone's he
only lived the blocks left my car walked
to hormones i go hey
i quit go yeah right [__]
everyone's playing games or smoking
we're going nah i quit
did you really quit i just quit bro you
quit twice this week
i know i know i quit twice
so two days later all right remember
that i quit
two days later so this is all within a
week still i get a call
and it's the mcdonald's number the
manager number oh no here it is here it
goes
and the the the dude the white dude goes
hey thomas um
you work here at the r street and go
just [__] you had to check
to see if i even worked at that one
you're my manager [__] that's
all i thought
these fools really don't give a [__]
about me and all over there
i'm super nice but anyway
he tells me are you going to be coming
in for your shift today it started
an hour ago and i tell him you
what he goes yeah are you still coming
in for your shift and that's when it
clicked
they still don't know i walked away
two times do they think the rapture
happened and only one nice [__]
got taken because all my clothes are
just left on the ground in front of the
meat section
that's what happened to me dude both
times just thomas
on the name tag trainee or uh
no no i wouldn't join you that's the
other one and just on the on the ground
i would think that would stop the whole
flow of the burgers no no no all they
did was
yo i don't give a [__] anybody says
mexican people are some of the hardest
working [__] on the planet
and i know that because my family is a
mexican family
and they're hardworking as people also
i've worked at mcdonald's
if you want your business to run just
get some mexican guys and mexican girls
that all
like each other and it's [__] over
that
they picked up they didn't miss a beat
obviously
i left and i guarantee you those burgers
didn't burn
they walked up with clothes kicked him
under the fryer
and started doing more [__] they did
miss a beat so that means
the first time they didn't know i went
back walked in obviously no one knows
the second time no one knew again
that was my day shift it was like four
o'clock
you didn't notice your your guy on the
meat is just gone and his clothes are on
the ground what if i got kidnapped
what is something that's happening
that's combustion disappeared
nothing happened you guys didn't check
the cameras you can call me for two days
[__] you you even check on my well-being
anyway he called me
your shift started an hour ago i told
him
hey i quit i quit two days ago man he
goes
did you but yeah i just quit
he goes oh yeah that's fine man come get
your last check you can pick it up on
this day blah blah blah
that was it he did did didn't miss me
all it did was somebody
met somebody else got more hours that's
what mcdonald's is oh
you're you're dying hey are you dying
well then you work here
that's that's that's how it is but i
understand they're a corporation or
business but damn bro
two times two [__] times and they
didn't notice me every job i ever had i
feel like i was
constantly walking around on the brink
of that every day
the entire time i was questioning myself
my life i was ambitious
everything's ready to spaz out over
nothing like it just
went against my soul the whole time you
know what it is i didn't have to do
customer service doing the meet that's
why i'm sitting there just going
dad from [__] christmas story that's
how i felt like
every five seconds someone talked to me
oh hi [__] you [__] you just
that's how i feel dude i just want to
implode so bad i hated that [__]
and um that's exactly what how i felt
during work but when it came to like me
and ed's
working at uhaul i mean we were five
star i mean we
ran a restaurant with just four of my
homies from high school
and the manager when he wasn't there we
were a five-star
rated restaurant bro it was a pizza
place
but we were killing it we were killing
it we were making gourmet ass [__]
and it was only because every time we
made food i'm like yo that looks like
[__] you're a [__]
because they're your friends so you want
to outdo your friend like no i make
better pizzas [__] you watch this guy's
face my hand is [__] pizza [__] you
that's how it tells there's a big ass
bag of weed in it
not not that i'm talking about i'm
talking about like oh your pizza looks
like [__] who [__] this up
who [__] this one up that's how it was
like oh who did it oh all right you did
it all right you're [__] up so we're
smoking weed later like hey remember
when you [__] up all those pizzas
today and you made us look stupid yeah
for sure
you know like the ridicule from your
homies so you don't want to be the guy
that's like
half-assing it because it's like yo get
the [__] out of here bro we're five
stars now we're getting paid you need to
get the [__]
so that's that's how i worked at that
place and
damn that was loud also used to be a
conductor
[Laughter]
what are the jobs that i had a bunch of
jobs i don't know oh yeah geds that's
how we got off in this topic
sorry for the rants guys but that's
gonna happen here
it's gonna happen a lot here sorry we're
almost an hour in
and i am two bullet points and to my
notes this is still the intro guys
still the intro still the intro bernie
mac music is still playing
just stopped here the intro's over
stereo is an app and brand new app that
just came out
you guys know we're in the chat we're in
youtube chat or any other chat
and it's there's thousands and thousands
of people in the chat
you're trying to talk to me get a
message across maybe a comment stereo
app is
basically our intimate version of live
chat so after the shows maybe
on a monday you're just hanging out
check out stereo app i'll always
announce when i'm gonna get on
it's a live chat it's just us do you see
what i'm saying this is a growing app
it's a platform that just started
so it's not like there's gonna be 500
000 people on the page
trying to talk to me at the same time
this is for us this is for the fans
this is for us to talk intimate bonus q
and a's
so what i want you to do right now right
now if you support our app
i mean if you support our platform do me
a favor go download this app it's a
stereo app in the app store download it
make an account
follow us dope as usual right now we're
working on getting verified
the first platform in the world to ever
[__] verify us guys
they play us so much but stereo shout
out to you thank you so much for
bringing us together
and actually being able to make a
[__] platform so we can talk
do you see what i'm saying it's not just
non-stop
[__] messages this is us this is
going to be just for the fans for the
dope as usual fans
and this is it so do me a favor guys if
you support the podcast
you want to see us do more of it this is
going to allow us to pay ourselves
go to the stereo uh go to the app store
right now and download stereo
check it out follow us dope as usual
after the show before the show we'll be
hopping on live
at least two to three times a week guys
we're gonna be using this platform a lot
so thank you guys so much for sticking
around to this long ass first ad read i
know i'm rambling here
but i'm grateful i'm super super happy
we're like everybody else we're like the
normal kids now we can actually
advertise
and not get [__] on because it's a wee
company this is real
stereo app in the app store now back to
the episode
okay here we go so what's the advice to
kids in high school then get
get the diploma don't get the diploma oh
graduate if you don't graduate you're a
little
[__] [__] come on it's the minimum
then again i almost didn't graduate but
i would have gone and did whatever i had
to graduate
dude i almost didn't graduate so heavy
and i remember the day my counselor said
going through my papers oh yeah you
missed too many units already
and i'm thinking oh my mom oh
no she is going to [__] kill me
that's all i kept thinking this
the right hook that she throws at me is
going to be devastating
and and he's doing my paper oh no no no
you're you're okay you're okay i'll give
peace okay you're the worst we're just
talking about this counselor this
counselor was a
mr denno mr dano i don't give a [__] if
you if you know if it's your family
remember
mr dano you're an all right counselor
but you're kind of a creep
all right just for the dudes man i don't
know what it was he would
come up to you and do this number you
guys ever have teachers or something
like this or like authority figures when
you're growing up do this
hey what's up man grab your shoulders
from both sides hey what's up man how
you doing how you doing he would grab
our shoulders and like
when we were just talking to our friends
in the hall oh oh what's up mr dano
and you know what i mean when you say oh
hi you look at your friend
[__] that's what i did every day hey mr
dano
[__] weirdo and he was just how you
doing man
all right keep those grades up but you
know my grades [__]
you just said i almost didn't graduate
keep those grades up what the [__] are
you talking about
i gotta ask you know what my grades look
like
anyway he told me that he goes all right
this is about four months before school
ended and i needed i don't give a [__]
it was like you need to start selling
chris
chris crack and and uh cocaine and then
we'll let you pass school and i would
have started selling
anything i could have that's the that's
the level of dedication i needed not
do your homework and be a good student
because i wasn't about that obviously
but i didn't want to when it came to
your mom's gonna find out i went oh
[__] what do you want me to do sir
who do i gotta stab to get on that stage
and get my diploma
and um he told me you're gonna have to
take a 1a period if you guys don't know
what that is 1a means the class before
school starts
did you know that's a real thing there's
a class
before high school starts you can come
in it starts at 6 30 in the morning
6 30 to 7 40. school starts at 8 15.
my bus i live on the other side of town
5 45
i had to be at my bus stop because i
live on the ghetto side
they had to take me to merced and it
took a long time to pick up all those
kids
5 45 i'm an insomniac can't sleep i'd be
going to bed at 4 or 4 30 waking up just
walking out and i would sprint i would
wake up later so i could sprint the
three blocks to the [__] bus stop
because i could sleep longer because if
i walk and take me 10 minutes if i
sprint take my four
i'm not kidding if i got a minute longer
of sleep i would take that [__] i used
to when i was younger dude in fourth
fifth grade i used to get dressed the
night before
and i'd wake up put my shoes on and
leave because i always walk to school
well usually i walk to school so any
sleep i could get as a kid
i would have took anyway he tells me one
a period
i said all right i'll take it goes oh
that's not oh
[__] man you're gonna lay it on me he
goes alright cool what do i need because
i missed 180 uh periods my senior year
and you're only allowed to miss 70 or 85
and i miss 180 and he's looking at me
like where have you been
oh you know sometimes i miss the bus you
know i live on this side of town i live
with my grandma i'm just giving those
tour my grandpa
you know he works 12 hours a day
sometimes i miss the bus i can't make it
here
i sometimes i'd walk to school if i
missed that bus i wouldn't miss that bus
and walk to [__] school
um it's [__] four or five miles away
i would walk in i don't give a [__] i
hated that [__] it was like
the warriors like just all right i made
it back 12th street i ain't gonna get
jumped by some crazy gangsters
oh [__] now i'm on 22nd street look out
for the [__] tweakers oh [__] now
it's
now we're on g street in olive gotta
make sure the truman officer doesn't
come snatch my ass up
that's what the [__] i was in even
though i was on my way to school true
officer was a piece of [__] officer
lucas was a [__]
[__] anyway he looked like he wanted
to be stone cold steve austin but he
wasn't like in shape
um the [__] am i talking about see this
is what this joint will do to you man
i'm sorry for everybody just like
driving like what the [__] is this guy
talk this is my life
all right other people didn't know
they're truant officers on a first name
basis and [__] so i think
obviously he's a [__] or even have
i thought true see officers were like a
thing in the 50s or something he's a
[__]
it's also merced bro um i'll tell you
another story about
wild wild [__] happened when i entered
high school some new some [__] got on
the news it was so crazy
um not even merced news the news of the
san joaquin valley like it was pretty
[__] bad
um
anyway yeah there you go i forgot
forever i was one a period and he says
you ready you're gonna have to take
saturday's schools like okay
[__] it's it's seven hours it's not like
the breakfast club
you can't walk around i don't give a
[__] what school they're at
in the breakfast club he just let them
do whatever the [__] they wanted they
smoked weed
screamed so loud they broke a window get
the [__] out of here
so it's not like the breakfast club i
had saturday school it was a super mean
man
um we all sat in one direction you
couldn't really do much but we did do
coke in saturday school because we would
pass it on a little book
on the right side of us clayton this big
mexican [__]
and this other mexican gangbanger dude
was in front and i remember when they
passed it back to me they were like
this is full cool and clayton's behind
me he's like oh no he's cool
and i hit a line i'm right headed line
to saturday school the first saturday
school i get there
and i look back and clean i'm like this
is what you do it goes all right it gets
we're gonna smoke weed on break too go
ah i love you like this is so cool i'm
just sitting and clayton used to sell me
coke so i'm not paying for coke i'm just
doing lines and saturday school just
sitting there doing nothing like i can't
smoke a cigarette i can't oh [__]
so i'm just doing lines at least it's
helping doing lines of saturday school
little bumps
nobody's saying a word that's merced
everybody else that's there for like
regular [__] it's like
[__] coke rocks on that [__]
imagine that like it's we're just
passing it this way
in case the teacher stood up he couldn't
see but if he came we just
blow it off what the [__] is he gonna do
what's that powder [__] it's
dusty in here i don't know what you're
talking about what's those rocks
[__] ground rocks i don't know [__]
you what do you want me to say
so we couldn't blame it on anybody if we
just went and blew it everywhere so that
was our technique right side from the
low underneath
um damn that was a different story so i
had saturday school thanks mr denno got
free coke
i got saturday school and adult class
night school
so imagine this guys i had my full
school right
every day one a period before class i
started class at 6 30 i get out at 3 15.
at 5 15 my night school starts monday
through friday
but on saturday i have eight uh seven
hours of saturday school
for the last four months of my senior
year i had to do every one of those
things do
all my work and i i just just caught up
and i got to graduate and walk
dude what a horrible last four months i
was
pissed you know when you did you give
your senior uh speech in your in your
not on stage but uh some schools they
write out your
goodbye to high school did you have to
do that i don't think so
we had to do that my [__] was so damn
short
it was almost as comical i i mean i gave
i did not give a [__] none of the kids
in my class i liked
they were all whack as [__] in that 1a
period
and i remember thinking this is it's my
last day of school oh this is all you're
getting
you're supposed to write a full page i
wrote a half a paragraph i wrote a
couple lines
hi guys this is high school blah blah
blah i'm really glad it's over i don't
ever have to be here again
for everyone out there that liked high
school that's awesome but i did not like
it and sat down
that was it i felt so accomplished i was
so
hyped and even my teacher missed little
she was so cool she even says i don't
know how you passed my class but you did
cause i would never do my work
i would never do my work in [__]
english class even though that's how i
passed
i just wanted to get a seat i just
wanted to get a [__] c
dude and if i got a c i got to graduate
i had a d
minus and then i did my paper and got an
a plus on it my essay
i'm a really good i'm a really good
writer i'm a good bullshitter i can
write on paper and just fill her in but
you'll still be reading
like you'll be interested and uh she
goes your paper was good you got an a
plus she's doing my
work for me she's doing my numbers to
see what my grade is because
if i don't pass her class i don't walk
you know what i'm saying it's like a
week before class
is over school's over and i'm looking at
her and she's doing the numbers i'm
sorry right [__]
give me that [__] she looks at me she
goes i don't know how you barely do any
of your work and you pass my class
and that was it and i graduated high
school man that's all i had i mean
that's not all i had to do
that's what i had to do to finish even
though i could've just been a good
student in four years
but the last four months i was a good
student crammed all into four months
so that's exactly how it went down i had
to walk back from night school
in the ghetto to the ghetto other side
of town and it ruined the movie that
departed for me
i walked in and my grandpa my uncle john
man pepper watch and departed i look and
go
oh is it departed and leonardo dicaprio
could shot the [__] face in the
elevator and i go
oh well i can't watch this [__] movie
now because this is done
and then i just watched the departed on
december when we were chilling for
christmas
this christmas i watched it that's how
long i waited because i was like
i know leonardo dicaprio does not make
it and that was it
that was night school for me it ruined
the departed
wow how did we get into that all ties in
how did we get into that man
we into these long stretches of [__]
nonsense oh
man that [__] just gave me anxiety
thinking of having to do school again
seriously i truly hate it for everyone
in school right now shout out to you
if you're involuntary school like you're
voluntarily going to college and you're
killing it good job
everybody that does good in school i
always admire because they have the
discipline to do it
i just don't i'm super smart with all
the subjects and [__]
like i was in all those gifted classes
and all that [__]
i just don't give a [__] it's sad it's
really sad but
i just uh that's just me
you know but i mean [__] what really
counts though what's the point of school
that's what i try to get to my kids like
i
never use the [__] quadratic
formula
selling packs i i know that for a
[__] fact it never helped me out
it didn't help me at the store but it
probably
any mathematicians out there let me know
what the [__] we use a quadratic formula
for because
i don't know it's just some [__] to piss
me off as soon as i saw x's
i was done i was as soon as i started
involving the alphabet into math
it's like okay there's going to be
people that dedicate their lives to math
they're going to be doctors
let's let them handle this oh
math student remember i said one math
student of the year miss seventh grade
mr mondo's class right
dude last year remember i told you oh
for everyone out there i was trying to
do the cartoon story time
too [__] expensive i ain't
doing that [__] that's a house payment
for like a [__] season no thank you
so i am sitting i'm having a drink at
this bar in hollywood it's a bar it's a
really nice restaurant we're at the bar
area
i'm with this dude that does a comedy he
does like a lot of
comedy central he directs a lot of
comedy central stand-ups right he does a
lot of stand-ups
and this other guy i'm with is my one of
my videographers
he brings me to go meet this man because
i want to do st like i want
to stand up a year and a half ago like i
was writing [__] out think of it
happened i went
all right i guess it's on hold so i went
to meet him and we're going to talk
about the cartoon story time talk about
some stand up i did like a five minute
like piece in front of him
just some material [__] that i wrote out
and he just gave me some critiques
[__] like that so i go meet this man
we're sitting there and it's a private
event it's before covent this is a
private event so there's only like
15 people at this one big-ass table in
the middle of this restaurant it's like
a really
dim lit italian restaurant um
so i'm sitting there i'm having the
meeting it's going well we do the little
comedy stand up outside we're smoking
joints
come back in he's giving me critiques on
what this is what i would work on
this is what i would work on right for
the stand-up [__]
i look over and i go remember
i'm in la i'm in hollywood
it's [__] 11 o'clock at night there's
having a [__] dinner party and we're
talking to the bartender and the guy the
the comedy guy
goes there every day so he knows the
bartender by name they're like oh yeah
they're having a private event for the
owner's uh son it's his friend's
birthday i look over who the [__] do i
see
mr mondo my seventh grade math teacher
i look at him like for real
can't be him so this lady walks up to
the bar and i know her
she was a teacher at tanaya that i went
to he ended up marrying
one of the teachers from tanaya i talked
to go miss delgado
she goes uh hello i go
you're miss delgado tanaya she goes uh
yeah
is that mr mondo she goes yes i go
wow oh my god if he has time tell him i
said hello this is thomas rojo from
tanaya middle school
and he remembered my ass because i won
that damn award i won the first it was
the first year he did that
math students of the year we had uh
there was like two or three winners
for across uh sixth seventh eighth grade
and he had a picture of us we're in the
yearbook
and um i think it's in the yearbook i
don't know i remember the picture
and it said math students of the year we
got a certificate i got [__] the reason
i really did it is because
you got a pizza party i only did [__]
for incentives as a kid man i got a
pizza party so i pretended to have
asthma
we talked about that one already for the
asthma club and i just got really good
at math because i wanted a pizza party
i was poor man i get no pizza party
anywhere
so and we gotta have the pizza party in
the middle of the lunch room during
lunch and no one else is about to go
there like oh everybody's gonna be
pissed
and i remember as i'm eating the pizza
thinking i don't like eating pizza in
front of everybody this feels weird
and uh damn i rant so hard anyway
he comes over like 15 minutes later we
start talking and it's just such a trip
man to see
you know what i mean when you remember
people when you're younger and go wow
you were like 30 when i met you when i
was a kid and now you're like in your
50s
it's so crazy to see the transition and
he goes yeah same room
still teach it tonight it was a trip
he's like same room same subject
it's so weird to see because we know
when you're in middle school and you're
thinking about what am i going to be
like in 25 and 30
and then you're there you know you think
back on all the times you saw
older kids think what are they going to
be doing when they're older now you're
doing what you're doing and to see my
teacher and he's asking me what i'm
doing he's like
you're doing what oh yeah we're gonna
make a show and
like what the [__] you moved out of
merced right yeah i live here because
that makes sense
because you got to leave merced if you
want to do some [__] filming [__] go
yeah man we moved down here a couple
years
we're over here meeting i have a meeting
and it's just it was so weird
to finally see you know what i'm saying
man it was such a shrimp
it was a trip and another thing sorry
another
sub rant subject i don't have facebook
i don't have a personal facebook i don't
see people
from high school i don't see people from
my town from a kid
i logged onto facebook because we were
making adobe's usual facebook and i have
to log in
and it suggested people from my area and
i just with that scroll bar you ever hit
that scroll bar
on facebook oh yeah and as i'm going
through it i'm just like
this happened and we it finally happened
we're all grown up now
because you know i always think of
myself as a kid and [__] but i'm [__]
31. i'm not a little boy anymore you can
look at these people and see
the wow yeah dude well when i see
tweakers and merced and they were my old
homies when i see tweakers that people i
used to know
that [__] [__] me up because i remember
like yo phillip you were at my seventh
grade myself
my 12th birthday party bro you slept at
my house
and now you're picking up cans it's it's
[__] insane to see it dude it is it's
really sad
it gives you compassion for people when
you can look at them and see the little
kid
like where you know i only see the
little kid and that's what makes me sad
looking at like
yo that's my homie if i can tweak in
holy [__]
all right we're on the same football
team bro what the [__] happened
it's just i'm not blaming anybody just
saying it's just so weird to think about
like
mercedes tweaked out so i'm getting to
the age where the tweakers outside
are now my [__] friends you know when
you were a younger 17 like get the [__]
away from me tweak her
you could try to come you got some got a
dollar i'm in high school [__]
i'm trying to get a swisher
i don't got a dollar for you yeah you
know seriously i broke i've shouted at
bombs before oh
no money fools will hound you like y'all
you got a dollar my sister used to do
that all the time
my sister shireen dude she's such a dick
any time we come across a bum and
they're about to talk to she goes hey
you got a dollar uh-huh
every time do you have a dollar and they
would leave me the [__] alone instantly
don't even talk to us anymore and ask
the person behind me
and i looked like you're an [__] she
goes i guarantee you they'll never give
me a dollar and they'll never talk to me
again
you're smart [__] and it works
you know the other change first thing
she asked get any change
oh it's [__] up it's funny it's
hilarious it's hilarious
she didn't do it to bum she did it to
drug addict [__] which is the
same thing when i say bum
i mean drug addict drunk you're outside
because you choose to be you dick
when i say homeless person i mean
someone outside that might be mentally
[__]
up might be down on their damn look [__]
like that
homeless person it's a homeless person a
bum
a tweaker is you know the difference
so if you ever come across like you want
to call homeless people bombs like well
if i'm calling them bums bums
yeah full chose to get my eight dollars
i gave him to go [__] by chris
[__] that guy so
the [__] are we talking about i've seen
i've seen you
very casually go and just give to
homeless people without even saying
anything
that's different though because if
they're nice if they look nice i'll give
people money
like if they look super nice
i don't know what it is there's a vibe
dude but that's there's a vibe most
people don't see that most people
see one thing like even me i see i don't
see the differences
like that there is because i grew up
around so many slummy-ass [__]
that there's people that walk up and go
fool your eyes aren't looking at me but
you're look you're talking to me i need
you to get the [__] away from me
when people stare through you when
they're [__] up get away from me
if people are asking for money and i
know they need money
that's different you know what i'm
saying like oh what's his name chris
remember
i met this random man named chris and i
remember his name because he was [__]
awesome i pulled up to the gas station
right before the grapevine
going to merced and this older white man
like he was like
75 working-ass dude you could tell he's
a working-ass construction
carpenter style dude you know the you
know those old white guys they got
cigarettes they got super deep wrinkles
you know you know what i'm saying with a
[__] hat the handlebar mustache
but i was pumping my gas and he came up
to me and i looked at him like hi
and he said oh hello i didn't know he
was a bum or anything he was living
outside
i couldn't tell because he you know i
mean he didn't look super dirty but look
like he was working
and he looks at me goes you wouldn't
happen to have any like
food or fruit or anything in your car
and i go
i i don't i i actually don't man because
usually i would
and he goes i don't know why god just
told me to ask you for some food
but he said it not in a weird cheesy way
he said it as he was leaving like
i don't know he told me to ask you he
said he said to ask you
huh but he was he didn't weird me out it
wasn't like he was trying to bait me to
what do you mean god don't like it
wasn't that i could feel it
so i gave him i don't know i gave my 20
bucks some [__] no no i bought him
food i bought a hell of food from the
gas station and gave it to him
and i come out he looks at me i was
right when you walked in there god said
oh he's coming right back don't worry
and so i waited out here because he was
standing right in the same spot when i
came out
i'm like this motherfucker's wild so i
gave him 20 bucks and he's like
oh my god thomas ryan go yeah chris man
have a good day
i always look for him at that gas
station he's never been there again but
i remember when i was leaving about to
hit the freeway i looked back and he
still
like this waving it was like
it wasn't a real guy does that make
sense it was like someone was like let's
see if this guy's a piece of [__]
let's see if thomas is a [__] [__]
i swear to god it didn't seem like he
was a real person
the old white man chris remember that he
was so cool man
he was such the right thing to do what
do you teach your kid i teach my kid to
mind her business keep her head down
don't [__] talk to nobody i know it
depends when [__] look
that you got can you differentiate
tweaking from homeless
can you differentiate drunk as [__] from
pilled out
i can so i see peeled out i see tweaking
go get the [__]
away from me if people ask me for money
they got the same they got shoes and a
phone like yo
when i was broke i sold everything i had
and i was
[__] you [__] you that's how i feel like
yo you have brand new nikes on get the
[__] away from me
i've had i i've almost that's one thing
about me dude i'll get real pissed when
people younger than me ask me for money
when they younger than me ask me for
money and it's like yo
go work i know a lot of old men in the
fields
[__] you [__] you i know hella fools
that work in the fields they don't have
to but they do because why because it's
a job
i it's something that really really
aggravates me dude
it makes me so upset people my age were
younger asking me for money
[__] you you have nikes on [__] you and
i get it
some people are down on the luck they're
outside how'd you get that marker
[__]
you just you know you just happen to
have a marker and a cardboard and you
just pick this corner
no you came out here willingly you have
a phone that's the thing that kills me
you got a phone on you
it's not a metrophone [__] you
have a phone you pay a phone bill
[__] you that's all because i know a lot
of old ladies and that'll all work
every time you see somebody selling
flowers every time you see something
remember that
they went out there for a reason that's
just oh that [__] aggravates me so much
i'm all like
i feel like a piece of [__] for feeling
like that too i feel like an [__]
when it's like i said it's the vibe of
somebody there's a
you guys are in la you know the african
dude the super like
super smiley african dude with the afro
on the side but he's bald in the middle
he stays
right there he asked for money right
there on that side street of temple
downtown going toward the freeway if
you're from l.a you know exactly what
guy i'm talking about he's slightly
dancing all the time
but you know what i'm talking about that
man is so [__] nice
he sleeps right there i see his tent but
there's a vibe of somebody like yo i
need to help this guy out today first
like
this is gonna help this man out and it
was just in my pocket you know what i
mean like when it's something like oh i
forgot i had five dollars in my pocket
here that's different that's why i give
i don't give money to everybody
[__] no there's a hell of [__]
out there get away from me
but when you come up and you see
somebody in the vibes right and you can
tell that they're like yo
could you help it's different when
they're like can you help out you say no
they walk to the next person that
[__] didn't care [__]
tweaking
get out of here get the [__] away from
me that's what pisses me i don't know
how we got in this topic
but that [__] pisses me the [__] off
that's [__] they don't teach you
i mean when does somebody sit down and
teach a kid how to deal with homeless
people my dad did
i was at betos which is now victoria's
burritos and merced and actually i
remember this
i've been doing this my whole life
because as a kid i used to try to feed
all the [__] straight dogs and [__]
by my house
because i felt so bad like where are
they going to eat you know as a kid you
don't think
yo you can't save every animal you can't
help every homeless because as a kid
when i went to frisco
and my mom like made me walk around a
guy sleeping on the ground
he had a jean jacket on he had a [__]
like the the tall like south park beanie
he was asleep white dude with a beard
i looked at him like what the [__] this
guy's asleep on the ground
and we got i was like four four or five
and i remember i'm holding my mom's hand
i asked her
like why is he asleep she goes he's a
homeless guy he's a bomb he sleeps
outside he's drug addict i remember
thinking
people sleep outside it's the first time
i've ever seen it we were we're in uh
in in san francisco on hate on hate
about to hit
no what i don't know what street is
we're about to hit that uh park that
park right there by amoeba
you know amoeba the record store right
before that street ends in amoeba
downtown frisco i don't know where it's
at anyway
that's the first time i ever saw a
homeless person and i remember thinking
how the [__] do we help this man that
sleeps on the ground who was gonna help
you don't understand that as a kid then
we're sitting at betos i was about
five i you guys know
or maybe you don't i've been working my
whole life i try to hustle
[__] money out of anything i can i'll
pick up cans graham you need anything
done
anything done i mean you got some change
right there i could have i'll clean the
whole kit
whatever i could i would do at work
anywhere so i
always had money as a kid i had like
four bucks on me and when i see money
four dollars is the world your three
now and leaders are like two for 25 back
then you don't need a lot of money to go
i'm a king so i had like four or five
bucks on me
at all times i had hella change in my
pocket i thought change was the [__]
that's silver oh you're a [__]
monster when you got those quarters
so i i loved nickels i don't know why i
get into this
i would collect nickels as a kid i would
spend them but nichols was my [__] i
think because they were heavier
anyway we're sitting there eating a
burrito with my dad and my sister at
betos which is across the street from
um stole save mart and this homeless
dude comes up
and he asks for change my dad goes now i
got a change man and i look at him
and i remember i go i have change and my
dad looks at me like stop
he looks at me across the table like
don't do
it he's trying to tell me without being
rude to the man like stop he's trying
not to be rude to the man asking for
money
but then again if you're a dude and
you're like you got any money
four-year-old five-year-old like you're
a piece of [__] you're getting money
from this little ass boy
um i reached in my hand i reached my
pocket my
hand in my pocket and i grabbed out all
the change in my pocket and i mean i had
a little kid two handfuls of change so
like a regular adult sized hand well
like four or five dollars man
and i remember i gave all my change to
this guy because he asked me and goes
you have any change guys i'm trying to
get uh try to get a burrito or
i'm trying to get up some food i'm
drinking a burrito because i was eating
a burrito i remember thinking dude he
don't got no food
i got a burrito i feel like a piece of
[__] you know as a kid you don't know
how to cope with oh he's got he don't
got [__]
now i know like you bum [__]
[__] you
um i gave him all the change in my
pocket i can hear my dad like
[__] you [__] he's looking at
the guy like
[__] you like you should be he was
looking at the guy like you're really
taking this change huh
so i gave him all the change some change
falls i get down i remember everything i
get down i give it to him
and he puts all his pockets thank you
and he walks away and as soon as he
walks in my dad grabs my hand and goes
don't give change to people like that go
dad he says he needs food he goes thomas
he's going to walk across the street to
that damn safe mart and get beer
dad why would he do that he said he's
getting a burrito
he's right at the burrito shop work he's
going to get food
i'm just trying to like nah dad you're
stupid like
i'm i'm over here like i got life
experience dad [__] you
and uh this [__] diagonally
jaywalked straight across the street
right to the store
did not get food he got my money and
walked
directly across the street didn't look
back didn't wait for the crosswalk just
walked straight through the middle went
straight to the store like my dad said
and that's the day i realized holy [__]
you can't give money to everybody
that guy did look like a piece of [__]
but as a kid i'm just trying to help
that's the day i found out marty so yeah
my dad did teach me
that's tough you want to be empathetic
but to me
i always i'm like to the point where
it's
the opposite i have my head down i'm
avoiding every
obstacle and everything that could
possibly take me off path at all costs
i i want to be i'm walking with a screw
in my hand mentally
that's all i heard right now man man i'm
i'm
literally looking past if homeless fools
don't ask you for money you just ignore
him
yeah i got my head down i'm looking past
everybody can't do it every possible
thing that could take me off my i really
wish i could do that man i can't i have
to like
i [__] conversate that's why i hate
those [__] at the mall
you wanna shine your shoes after i tell
them 76 times no i'm good i'm still
standing there trying to be like
i promise man i'm good thank you and i'm
just i can't be
i can't be like that that cold to people
walking into target or walking into
walmart when they hit you up
one on one walking into walmart and then
they'll hit you with the god they'll
bring god into it
as they do that i go get the [__] out of
here pushing god on me don't try to
[__] con me into feeling bad and
saying this is for god
if it's for god work for free oh you
know you make money
i'm trying to too that's where it's at
what was it like the sign field
oh you don't want uh telemarkers people
calling your home oh now you know i feel
exactly same [__] yeah there's a fine
balance between
like i want if you know when we get
successful i'll
me and april are gonna talk about it
there's nothing more that we're gonna do
then give back and find ways to help
other people that are deserving come up
along
i have the path and stuff for that want
to hear my idea
it sounds devious it is
so so when i get rich this is what i
want
to do when i was younger
i was poor as [__] and i was always
imagining some rich ass dude walking by
me and my mom
randomly and going hey here's ten
thousand dollars you guys pay your bill
like i always imagine somebody would
do that you know like somebody's gonna
do something where
somebody help that's all i keep thinking
as a kid like it's gonna happen i wish
i was like my grandma's like i wish like
a plane would just drop something and
it's just a stack of money and we can do
see
i always imagine someone's going to help
us randomly so
this is what i want to do when i get
rich you know you got to pay taxes no
matter what
but if you give it to charitable things
i can eat into your taxes
so instead of paying the government the
taxes
i want to start a thing where i
walk around and when i see really nice
or polite people i just drop 10 stacks
on them
so if you're in the store and you see
some
college student and you know they're a
college student and you could see them
like buying only the little things go
hey man you're in school
yeah well talk to him for five minutes
like i'll talk to him okay cool
by the way i'm rich as [__] please don't
say no to this take this and go do some
[__] with it here take this
take it that is going to be the funnest
[__] ever to j marty drop
10 stacks on random people with their
kids at the store
i remember one time uh my friends and i
thought we won the lottery and i bought
uh everybody dinner and i thought i was
a baller we had
denny's wait all right don't pass that
what do you mean you
thought you won the lottery how do you
think you win
and then start spending one of my good
friends called me
freaking the [__] out literally freaking
the [__] out talking about he had hit it
and there was a period of that whole
night i'm talking about quit your job
all this [__] i was like wait he thought
he won yeah
so how is he so dumb that he didn't it's
a good question
i didn't at the in the moment it didn't
register to me that there was a
possibility he hadn't
actually wanted stupidity or a prank it
wasn't a prank
i don't i'm not sure what it was but
that night we def i was
i was thinking about the bends i was
going to get the next day and the whole
[__]
and yeah bought like 10 people dinner at
denny's thinking out that was the most
ballerina fiction i ever did in my life
the most
ballerina i spent seventy two dollars i
didn't
even leave a tip oh i don't know
but yeah that man no what happened
don't just stop people in the car go
what the [__]
wait so what did he say by the way i
didn't win
man i'm yeah basically i was in my job
the next morning because we worked in
the same building
ready to quit the job just basically
waiting on confirmation from him and i
got like some sort of weird like
ah you know like i was off or some [__]
but it was bad it was bad that that was
a really big life lesson to me to be
like
never react to anything until it's
[__] confusing until it's completely
done and in your pocket and done even
beyond it being done it needs to have
been done for a while before you react
to it or talk about it
oh yeah and the last thing you want to
do if you win the lottery is go [__]
talk about it but
what i i don't give a [__] had we done i
would have quietly took my [__] and
backed away slowly i know they got that
lottery curse
but i think that's for dumb
[__] first if i won 100 mil
tomorrow
i'd have 200 mil next year yeah what the
[__]
yeah i'm like no it's investing at that
point it would have been long gone
oh yeah like i said don't give kids
money yeah you can't
you can't do it it just ah
it just doesn't work man well luckily i
never had that problem
neither [__] um
oh god this is rant city we live in rant
city all right
let me get back onto my [__]
schedule you guys ready
um i want to bring something up that's
kind of topical
everyone's leaving california guys me
and rosie have already looked at houses
in vegas
everyone's leaving california right
i think i know why obviously
we all have our own opinions on why but
i think i know what the
key to it is i think
everyone's making california trash right
now by upping the prices there's no
money to be made here
the cost of living is [__] stupid all
the comedians left
so a lot of that that world is gone they
all left because they're making money
and they can't do shows here why pay
higher taxes
totally reasonable the [__] that's what
i'm thinking too right
so i think when this all blows over
when everybody leaves and everybody's
like no we're gone
we're not gonna be here we're gonna be
out here for three years california's
done for now
i think the banks are gonna buy up all
his property at the lowest it's ever
been
and then they're gonna make california
cool again in like four years
and once california's cool again that
celebrity that sold their house in
california and moved to texas
now comes buys their house back for a
higher rate
four years later and the banks go good
we just need to clear out some people
because there's too many [__]
here but the people that want to return
and pay
you can live here that's the only thing
is going on with california right now
i think i don't know because people are
leaving right
yeah you know we grow everything we grow
all up
we are the agriculture [__] we
grow all the weed
we do everything here and you want to
leave it's because of taxes i get it
but at the same time this is the dopest
spot
that's the reason for it period yeah i
got strong feelings on this
that's the whole point yeah we man we
when we
we moved out here it just i don't know
when you come from somewhere else and
you come out here and it's a culture of
at least in orange county where nobody's
actually from there
it's people from all over the world
where you live is different you live in
the dopest part of california you live
in the
the pleasantville of california oh my
god marty lives
by in orange county the difference
between orange county and la is
staggering even though it's for you
ready
this is l.a all ashy and nasty
and this is where marty lives
everything's clean and symmetrical
there's nobody sleeping on the ground
it's bomb out there remember i said
this is the pinnacle of chill i went by
the in and out i passed it and there was
two cars in the
[__] drive-through this place is
chilling nobody's in a rush
nobody's crowding there's not 800 000
tourists at the same spot
you live in a really cool place but it's
all so far
yeah but i mean it's worth it for you
it's totally [__] worth it yeah
especially we have kids and [__] you got
to
be mindful of hey kids go to school
don't touch the bums
stay off skid row none of that yeah you
don't have to worry about that [__]
it's all where you live is the [__] that
you see on tv like where they live in
the new guy
remember the new oh not the new guy hot
chick with rob schneider
that neighborhood that's kind of like
where you live i love it it's so nice
yeah it's beautiful we went we're going
to buy a couple houses in texas or
whatever like two years ago we went
there and i just realized like
oh i can't it's just it's part of me now
no hate on texas
but once you're in california for a
while it's like
it's bomb out here it's just different
it's just different i don't know it was
so
it's i feel for me like it's different
than most people like where i lived in
me is
more important than it is but just
because i felt
so out of place for so long it was such
a massive goal to even be able to just
even
visit out here the fact that we're we're
we live here and you found a
house and [__] i'm astonished every day
every day i ride around the blue skies
the palm trees the mountains it's never
lost on me i'm always
i feel back like and you know
oh dude every time i get in my car every
time i push my [__] car and it starts
to go
[__] kidding me dude theo was just
driving and i saw on his instagram
there he had his instagram story about
uh he's driving in the snow
and all this [__] i'm like i bet you
never had your doors freeze open
while you're trying to drive and you got
to try not to fall out as you're driving
no
that's that's preposterous you can't be
doing that [__] that's
reckless i gotta get there though but
your doors froze open
i'll just not to fall out there's a
driving ban well we still need you in
your cubicle
no yeah you know the fact that that you
live in a place that like no no it's
it's the day after tomorrow out here
jake gyllenhaal's here
and um everything is frozen wait was
that chick chilling
it was him the after tomorrow was stupid
but it was really cool as a kid
everything froze over like sub-zero was
there that [__] was hard
yeah dude every time i get in my car
every time i
pull up to my house or my i just go
are you [__] kidding me i'm stoked
ever
not even like yeah every day it's more
of like [__] serious
yeah it's like an amazement yeah i'm
amazed every time dude every time i do
anything like
i never thought this would happen never
thought this would be possible like
when i was selling packs and just
thinking what am i gonna be doing i
gotta i gotta think something else
it's fun you make money selling weed but
it's like i can't do this forever
when you go after something that's
seemingly impossible and then it
actually starts to happen
it's really really i haven't done that
yet because everything i've done is just
random but
[__] look where we're at right now but
you know i mean it was random like i
didn't try to do weed [__] i didn't try
to do this like
it just happened this is the first thing
we've tried to like know let's do it
let's do
this so yes seeing this like i said
earlier today
when we were fixing the light me and
marty fixed this for the fifth time
today we were doing i said what
i can't believe these walls are here
yeah i still can't believe these walls
are right here
remember there's just a bear there's a
door right there we forgot
we [__] covered the door
i forgot that it opens this way we
didn't realize it opened the other way
it's okay today we [__] filled the
skylights
we're we're doing some shaving warehouse
right we're trying to there's a lot of
[__] nobody wants
any clue about do so much [__] in this
place man it's fun
i love this warehouse dude it's super
sick
but yes i want to get back onto my topic
let's try
slow the rant city down for a little bit
i love this you guys let me know
in the comments or if you're not if
you're listening on the platforms like
google podcast apple spotify you can't
leave the comment but
well maybe you can if you leave a review
but if you're on youtube you're on the
clips channel or the regular channel
let me know do you like the solo
episodes like not having a
we're gonna have guests we have guests
booked i'm saying
do you like these solo episodes i like
doing this this is fun as [__]
you guys are the guest so i'm just
talking to you you know i mean marty's
here to help
like bring [__] up on the screen where
it's fun to me it's just more of i
like the solo ones but i also like the
guests but i want to know what your
opinion is
let me know that's basically what i'm
saying let me know what you guys think
um i'm gonna get back on schedule
because i have
um some topics all right i have some
topics i wanted to talk about
if you ever see me do this and pretend
that i'm like just uh i'm just looking
at my notes all right
just looking at my [__] notes
over here okay that was my california
you ready here we go guys i'm gonna tell
a story real quick
i'm gonna tell a story and i've never
told this story before
and people well i've talked about it
i've never told the full story
and i know if you have if you follow me
on youtube or anything
if you don't check it out dopaziola on
youtube check it out
i do something called story time and uh
i've not used this people keep asking me
to do a story time on this topic
but i'm just going to do it today all
right here's the story time in the
podcast here we go i've never talked
about the story
let's run it 2015
i live in merced still it's 2015. i just
moved out of my little house with rosie
and we get a bomb house
we finally get like a super well i
always say
we live next to the white ladies now
that's what i always say my goal
is to live we're all like the super
target looking families like the white
families look
because you know that's a bomb
neighborhood i want to live where all
the neighbors go
what's up hey you see that game like
yeah
don't talk to me i don't i don't i don't
want to i smoke weed over here
you're gonna get mad at me i'm just
saying i want my neighbors to have that
mentality of like
you need to borrow something you let me
know because that's just like the
epitome of i made it
that and drinking grape welch's grape
juice the day we got this house
when i was a kid i go having air
conditioning and being able to drink
welch's grape juice
not grape drink welch's grape juice in
the glass jar
that's when you know you [__] made it
like that's that's literally the epitome
of wealth
or not wealth of success uh 2015 i
finally move out of my little ass
trap house and we get a real house like
we get a bomb house to where you think
how the [__] are these kids living here
first day i put the air conditioner on
there's a fan and i put the fan on
and i bust into my [__] grape juice i
went to the store and got a
glass of welter's grape juice the glass
bottle i bought two bottles
and i poured them put them in the fridge
i'm drinking it with my air conditioning
like
and i remember thinking i finally made
it i'm not kidding dude i've never had
air
like it's it's hot it's always the swamp
coolers and they give you [__]
sinus infections like i have right now
and um
yeah that's the day we moved there
anyway
multiple neighbors came over like so
where's your parents oh you just you
guys here
are you guys college kid like they kept
asking like why do you live here
how the [__] do you live in the house
next to me anyway they're dicks
our neighbors whatever cool the reason
i'm bringing this up is because
it's a big deal none of my even my
homies really have a house with the
parents like that
see what i'm saying we had two or three
extra rooms we just
one was a closet one was a film room
almost i mean we just had it
it's a bomb house i just loved it i just
felt like finally made it cool we have a
real good house like bring your mom over
rosie we'll eat food
he was fine like one of those you feel
like proud as [__] the yard was
eight feet long and we went outside he's
like yeah it's rocks there's some
some grass over there all right [__]
this hard i ain't going back here i
gotta smoke weed outside
and anyway it was a big deal
so obviously i was on instagram still
you know doing my [__]
but i'm still in merced still a small
town
so i don't know how it happened but this
is what happened
so we have the reason i bring the house
up is because now on instagram you see
this kid
hosting this giant house you see what
i'm saying now
if you're any type of law enforcer you
go what the [__] this [__]
doing
me posting that house was the equivalent
of rappers posting money
you know what i'm saying it's just you
just made yourself hot what are you what
are you doing
but i'm just sitting here smiling like
holy [__] we got a house yeah and little
i know [__] hating ass law
enforcement's looking at me like
what are you doing to get that house so
they obviously looked at me that's when
i started getting looked at
at that moment is when a lot of pushed
all
all of our clothing packages from push
trees started getting opened
seized regular shirt we don't ship weed
[__]
i'm not stupid i got a business license
and [__] i'm not risking my license to
ship weed
i don't even sell weed and
all of our package started getting open
people email us hey my package is not
here the tracking just stopped
that would happen tracking cool tracking
all the way to their town stopped
get to the facility stop tracking
numbers erased
like like we never sent the [__] can't
file a claim nothing
has happened like a hundred times me and
rosie are just
whoa what what happened we just lost all
that money and we got to refund that
person
so a couple days go by and then people
email us my package just showed up
no tracking number left no nothing that
just package just shows up at their door
every one of them says there was a note
on it like they were
for the first ones there was a note in
it saying that it was seized and
searched
it's now in a different bag with the
same thing the same
uh what is it called like the
information
stamp thing they cut that off put it on
a new bag
because they ripped my bag open and
taped it all shitty
the cops basically went [__] there's no
weed in here [__] wrap this piece of
[__] shirt up and sent it
so that kept happening like searched and
seized what the [__]
oh what did i do like what the [__] did
i do
they must think i sell we push trees i
think we sub weed
i was showing hello packs on my channel
making videos
understandable it kept going on and it
kept happening and it kept happening but
it started
this started when we got that house all
right
so everything's going along and at this
time
i was selling hello shirts to this dude
this dude i'm not gonna say his name
[__] this dude full still owes me money
[__] him
anyway little piece of [__] that's a
whole nother story
when we were still friends and
everything was cool i was giving him
hella shirts hella pushed tree shirts
and he went to the to the uc
and he was slanging the [__] out of the
shirts because people knew i was from
merced
i had a big following i'm not going to
meet up with you i don't meet up with
people i have the drug dealer mentality
i don't know you
i'm not meeting up with you it's not
going to happen i'm not going to sell
you shirts it's not worth it to my time
to
almost get robbed it's just not going to
happen and plus this merced i'm not
no thank you so that was my mentality
but they knew that i knew this guy
because i posted them on my page wearing
a shirt once
and they all started hitting him up like
yo can you get shirts can you get shirts
so he comes over my house and smokey one
day and says hey
i got a lot of people at my school
asking me for your clothes
what do you think about me selling your
shirts for you in town
that way you if you don't want to sell
them online or if you have extra i'll
just take them to school
i'll just give you the money for them i
go cool [__] yeah that sounds awesome
everybody merced be rocking it i just i
can't just go meet up with people i'd
say like
100 100 people go made up 100 people
with 100 different shirts just to make
that little bit of money
it was too much for me you know what i'm
saying it's not going to happen
so he started selling shirts and he was
selling them fast as [__] and i just
gave him all that wholesale so he can
make money he was just about to have a
kid
so i'm like yo you make you know profit
on it i'm just happy people are rocking
it merced
you go sell it we're all good we're
doing this for months and months and
months
he also was selling me mushrooms right
he was selling me
bags of mushrooms and i was eating a lot
of mushrooms at the time i never sold
the mushrooms
i was just eating them a lot if you
follow me for a long time remember those
sick ass pictures i was taken to those
mushrooms
i really wish instagram didn't hate on
me but i had some good ass videos eating
those mushrooms
super cool [__] weird trippy [__]
with the mushrooms taking cool pictures
so i was posting them a lot i was
posting bags of mushrooms just because
it was fun that's why everybody else can
right little i know those bags of
mushrooms were another red flag
automatically
and that is the time i started getting
looked at
so let's jump ahead a little bit the dea
drug enforcement agency comes to merced
the little asmr said
for why for me dea comes to merced and
sets up shop
right sets up wherever the [__] they
stand up probably
if it's a movie they in an abandoned
warehouse like that's what i imagine
like some
some wayne's world [__] you ever see
what goes on to those guys training
that's how i imagined it right so i'm
like i didn't know this at the time but
i'm just telling you dea is a merced i
didn't know this at all
weeks are going on weeks are going all
weeks growing by my packages are still
getting searched
still the same tags seized some of them
disappeared
they started just throwing my [__] in
the trash whoever was searching my [__]
just started throwing it away like the
shirts would just disappear
they were giving them all and sending
and resending them and then it just
started turning into
every five out of a hundred or every
every one out of five
thrown away i have to re i lose the
money then i gotta reimburse the person
and then send it out
i was losing money on these packages it
was pissing me off and the package
was non-existent so when i hit up the
post office like yo get my refund
what are you talking about we don't have
that this doesn't even exist
but they didn't know that you see what
i'm saying the government is over here
searching my [__]
throwing away my packages so
here it is i'm buying a lot of mushrooms
from this guy
right posting them all that stuff
he comes to my house one day he techno
he texts me one day
he goes hey i need to talk to you but i
need to talk to you in person and
automatically i'm like
hmm he's not going to rob me
you're not going to shoot me he's cool i
know where he lives and where his mom
stays
i'm doing all these things like if we'll
pull some [__] i know exactly where to
go to find
you know i know him but also hey i need
to talk to you but only in person
red flag i don't like that already and
then
i go okay let me know when you're going
to come by i just say that and the whole
time i'm thinking
nah and i get over the fact that i get
over the thought of
he ain't gonna rob me he's not gonna do
some weird [__] he's not gonna bring
nobody else we're cool
so then i start stressing like what is
going on that he can only tell me in
person
so i get a little that's when i started
getting like panicky like [__]
[__] what did i do what did i do no i
didn't sell nothing to no buyer
no i don't sell these all right i'm
going through all the things i can
possibly go to jail for i'm like no
i'm good i make videos i'm like nah i
make videos man i'm good
we're fine he comes over and he has the
look
he the look on his face like someone
killed his dog he had the look and i'm
like
no what happened like first thing i
think like
what the [__] is going on did somebody
shoot like
what happened [__] and why i remember i
closed the door he walks by my couch
usually we sit and chill and smoke but
he walks my my house into the kitchen
and i fall in the kitchen
and he turns around right by my toaster
terence puts his like elbow on my
counter and looks at me and goes
all right i'm gonna tell you something
i'm gonna go [__] you what's going on
man
it's not good i don't like where this is
going this is scaring me
like what what's [__] going on he
goes dude so you know how my friends so
and so i'm not gonna say names you know
my friend so-and-so
one of his best friends his dad's a cop
oh yeah i know
and he's no he's a detective not a cop
he's a [__] detective
and he goes so i was talking to my
friend
so piece of [__] [__] the one that's
selling me the mushrooms remember i told
you he's a piece [__]
his best friend his dad's a cop a
detective
he tells me what his friend told him are
you ready for this
i have a big following they know him
from merced my piece of [__] friend
follows me obviously because he sells
the clothes
he's like selling my clothes for me his
best friend follows me too because
obviously he's talked about i'm like yo
i'm selling clothes for this guy check
out his [__] instagram
all that you know the spiel
is watching my videos all that [__]
right
his dad comes home from work his dad's a
detective
comes home from work sits him down so
this is what he's telling me the story
his dad the detective tells his son
which is the guy selling my shirt that's
his best friend so this is dad
he says i know you know that guy the guy
from from instagram we know you know
that guy thomas
and he's like what the sorry am i this
is what i'm imagining he's saying like
what the [__] how do you know this
because i know you watch his videos
i know you know him you have his shirts
i'm just letting you know
i need you to stay away from him and the
guy the guy the kid says
i don't know him that's what's his
friend's fate that's what's his i can't
say his name let's call him piece of
[__]
that's piece of shit's uh friend thomas
i almost said his [__] [__] ass name
um let's just say best friend best
friend his dad's detective
piece of [__] friend is telling me the
story and he's the detective tells him i
need to stay away from i don't know if
you know him but
i know you and piece of [__] friend hang
out with him and he goes no no i don't
know i never met him because i told him
hey please don't bring people to my
house
uh when he was coming to get the clothes
because i don't want people to know
where i live so i've never met his best
friend i have no idea what he looks like
nothing i just know that's his best
friend cause he's mentioned him
sorry for the confusion i know it's
confusing he says i know you stay away
from him
some shit's going on and you need to
stay away stay clear don't go to his
house don't hang out with him piece of
[__] friend
if he's over there don't go with him try
to stay away from him
some stuff's going down and this guy is
telling me this in my kitchen
and i'm imagining his best friend like
looking up at his dad like what do you
mean
let's go i'm trying to like play the
scenarios in my head you know i mean my
[__] imagination's going crazy
because i'm saying like what do you mean
the detective's saying my [__] first
name
what are you talking about you know when
you get that little handshake and you're
like
like that shake up your spine where you
get a little nervous like what do you
what do you what do you mean what do you
mean
he goes so his dad tells him that the
dea is in merced
they're here because they're
investigating and they said
dope is yola thomas araho they knew my
[__] name before i ever said my name
on the internet
they have my name he says i just got
back from a debriefing
we are on the we are watching him we're
no
he said we're watching where he's at
because they knew where the [__] i lived
all right they knew where the [__] i
lived they say we're watching his
packages from his clothing company
he knew everything that was going on
with what the [__] was going on with me
he says the dea is here he says
your friend's name your friend's
pictures on a board you saw your friend
has a picture on a board with his name
and they're trying to figure out they
thought are ready are you
ready for what the [__] the dea of the
government wasted their stupid [__]
money on
they thought i was shipping mushrooms
out the second i started posting those
pictures is when i moved into that house
that's when my package started getting
[__] with they thought i was shipping
mushrooms
because i was posting i mean i was
supposed to like five packs but still
they thought it was shipping mushrooms
guys he looks at me and goes
hey he said that your picture's on a
board with your full name your instagram
pictures and everything with the
mushrooms
and they're trying to figure out what
post office i'm going to to ship them
out what ups i'm going to what fedex
as he's telling me this all my fears
just go away you know i mean like
as he's telling me this like i'm like oh
bro for real
you're selling me mushrooms i was
thinking like
you're the one selling me mushrooms what
do i gotta worry about
and then i thought wait
they know i saw weed and at that time at
that time
i wasn't selling wheat anymore but i
definitely knew
where to send people to get it i'm not
gonna say i was sending people to go buy
packs but i would
i'm not gonna say i didn't go hey i know
my friend here's his number i wasn't
doing that
i'm saying that now but i was scanning
my head of like
wait if they're investigating me and i
always have pounds here
i was smoking
but if i have pounds here they can bust
my door and i'm done like this is done i
am now going to i'm getting
it's california not going to go to
prison but now i can't get a license
anymore i can't [__] do certain
things you know what i'm saying
my income is going to get looked at it
was not
fun at that time so he told me that it
was for shipping mushrooms
and he says are you shipping the
mushrooms i sold you i'm like
are you wearing a muffin wire on your
chest do you think i'm shipping the
mushroom i bought a qp
from you [__] and i told you how much
fun it was eating them
you piece of [__] he was coming and
smoking weed in my house so at that
point i was like wait
are you the one shipping mushrooms out
and i thought
are you shipping my mushrooms are you
shipping mushrooms with my
[__] shirts of course it was you see
what i'm saying are you shipping my
shirts and mushrooms
are you the guy they're looking for and
are you and that's what i thought like
oh my god are you in the [__]
just doing this walter white [__]
it's some [__] is what it is and
he told me that i go bro i'm not
shipping mushrooms i don't give a
[__] and i told him is that why my
package hasn't been going
and he goes oh see he said you're
packing
because the detective said we've been
seizing his packages searching his [__]
cause they thought i was really shipping
[__] out
through push trees so guys i had a whole
dea investigation this went on for weeks
right
i was so scared and cautious i didn't
even want to go buy packs i didn't want
to do anything at that point i was
nervous as [__]
only because i was thinking if they find
out it's not me shipping shrooms they're
going to be
so pissed that they're going to try to
find anything just to make sure they got
something in merced and left
you see what i'm saying they're going to
spend money to come down put agents here
they're going to
they're i'm driving a [__] 86 ss
money
it's not hard to spot me in little
merced you can follow me
you know it's not hard to follow the
trail of smoke
literal trail of smoke going down g
street so of course they're watching me
they know where my house is they know
everything about me they have my full
[__] name they got my address they
got my water bill they got my light they
got everything
guess what about three weeks later of me
stressing the [__] out
what happens piece of [__] friend comes
to my house to get more shirts
huge smile on his face goes yo guess
what they caught the [__] ship
in the mushrooms out of here
so the guy got caught at the [__]
post office because they finally caught
a package
and this [__] dumbass put a return
label a return address on it
out of all the ones he shipped he put he
must had somebody else drop it off that
day
somebody whoever packaged that one he
must have been shipping hundreds of
packages
put a return address on one like a
[__]
dumbass dumbass never do that i'm not
saying go ship drugs
never put a [__] return address
[__]
he put his own address right
they were at the post office next time
he came and they snagged his ass he was
shipping mushrooms just overnighting
mushrooms to people
from merced so in the end they did catch
somebody but it wasn't [__] me
and i'm so happy i've never talked about
that [__] out loud
one whole question that was a
coincidence what do you mean
that guy randomly just got they just
find this dude no no no
no because they had very intercepted
packages so they were assuming that they
were me
yeah see what i'm saying they already
intercepted some packages so that's the
thing with the cops i'm gonna tell you
that right now if you're shipping
mushrooms you're shipping weed
let me give you some [__] advice and
knowledge they know
they know they ready you're the [__]
dea
this kid's shipping mushrooms this kid's
shipping weed we know he goes to this
address overnight in new york he goes to
this address in florida overnight he's
done it three times
probably weed if he's doing one to two
day most likely right
and not too heavy probably weed oh it's
kind of heavy shakes probably cartridges
we're gonna check these out little do
you know [__]
they cut those packages the [__] open
check that it's weed
and they let it go through they tape it
right the [__] back up
and they let it go through and you're
going no they don't that's [__]
stupid they'd get you right now
no no no that's called building a case
on your ass
they're built they they're just letting
them go through so they can go
when they're sitting you down at the at
the [__] jail and going hey we got
16 packages with you man they could have
got you on the first you would have got
in trouble for one stateline cross
international or
interstate sales now they got you on 15.
and once you got 15 they go
hey you know what your sentence is who
are you getting it from and you get a
lesser sentence and they get that guy
they get that guy they get that guy and
they get that guy
i'm telling you bro that's how this
works so all your [__] shipping
oh i made it through my packs always
land they always let
you might think they're always landing
but they could be getting
seized and searched and letting it go
through to build a case on you
that's all it is you have to be careful
i'm not advising shipping
but if you are one of these guys please
be [__] safe wear those damn latex
gloves
stop take those serial numbers off the
[__] boxes
i know how many people i see sleeve
serial numbers on [__] you think you
can't find the serial number where the
[__] that was sold
where it was me find the [__] cam
footage of whoever the [__]
bought that [__] have you seen tv shows
that's how it works if i could say that
out loud right now
i can find you if i'm the government hey
i get access to your cameras because
we're the government
okay who bought it at this time cool
same guy from the [__]
all right yeah that's him that's all it
takes when people ship
clothes with packs [__] take the
tag out
take the tag off you're leaving the
barcode on your [__]
you know how many times i've seen i've
rosie my girlfriend used to work with my
best friend jesus at a postal place
there was a guy that used to sell packs
and ship them there and they know that
they sell packs and shipping there
because if they have a suspicion they
have to open it by law
are you ready this guy i remember that
one time this guy
sold try to ship a pound out there in a
box
with nothing else in the box and when i
mean nothing else
no padding no foam
no bubbles nothing it was just sliding
around
just not even in a bag it was right
it was in a turkey bag
yo i know people that worked at
wholesale places that found bricks
bricks of coke oh man when you come
right you ready the biggest come-up of
the century is being a pulse to worker
if you're a postal worker and you know
what's going on you bought a house
you bought a [__] house man
because you know how easy it is to go
well i'm going to keep this because the
person that sent it is not gonna want to
go to jail
i'll keep it i'm gonna sell it to my
friend at half price and thank you for
my two thousand dollars
that's how easy it is um so stop
shipping [__]
it's just not worth it anyway that's my
dea story on how the dea wasted money
coming to get my
my little ass they didn't get [__]
because i don't do nothing stupid
i'm making videos um but yeah
there we go guys that's my dea story
i've never told that [__] in full
also to just sum it up the reason i call
him piece of [__] friend
is because i gave him like 1500 worth of
shirts
never heard from his little ass again
we've been doing this over and over and
over i was letting him keep
most of the profit because he was just
about to have a kid
and then this [__] ghosts me on
[__] i pay
taxes on i felt so played man
i felt so stupid but that's why he's
called a little piece of [__]
and i've known that fool since he was a
little kid
i knew him he's younger than me too so i
knew when he was hell a little when i
was younger too like
bro you played me those are the ones
that try to get you
the thing is dude even though that
pisses me off i'll never
[__] with him again that [__] is
cool as [__]
he's cool as [__] i really like his ass
he's one of the cooler dudes i knew from
merced i really [__] with him he's cool
as [__]
and he pulled some [__] on me that's
a shame such a shame dude i went to his
mom's house like
70 times trying to find his ass
to get my money back in here no when i
opened you know what made me really sad
when i opened the door when she opened
the door his mom
the first time i went over there go hi
is a
is so-and-so here and she looks at me
and goes
does he owe you money first thing she
says
i felt real bad because even she went
like [__]
does he owe you money first thing she
said and she knew
of me before the first time i went over
there after he dodged me
she said that [__] to me i talked to
like four other people like yo
he owes me money oh i'm never getting
that money back
i just left it alone after that like
it's over i ain't never getting it back
i'd rather have no money and i'd rather
it never happened because he was such a
cool [__] and that's what pisses
me off
i really a lot of the people that i'm
not friends with i will never [__] with
again i still love those fools
i just can't trust them so i can't be
around them it doesn't affect it though
that doesn't change how you feel about
them like that
oh oh oh i think when i say that they're
done to me forever yeah but if i can go
like this
everything was sick for this last part
to hear i can go
this part sucks and this is where i'm at
but everything before
oh i was so bomb i had a lot of friends
i still love to death and i
will beat to death i can't have them
around me just get away from me i don't
want to [__] fight you
could people piss me off i want you it's
just when people really try to play you
and when people play me and i feel like
duped
like damn dude you you were my friend
and you really pretended to be my friend
well that's what i'm getting at that's
what wrote times before the happening
like you weren't really the dude but
they might have been and there's
something opportunity arose where
they're like i'ma [__] you over you're
not that cool friend of me
you played me so well yeah like that's
what makes me upset
dude like you play me well dude i would
have [__]
did anything for your stupid ass man
i've been in those situations
god i hate that feeling dude a lot of
dudes i grew up with they'd be like nah
i know that about him so it's cool like
i would never put him in a position to
be able to get me like that but we can
be friends because i know that about him
i had different expectations for people
i know you're capable of some [__]
yeah like if i knew you'd do that [__] i
wouldn't have been your friend
to begin with i can't be friends with
you knowing that you do
that you do [__] like that yeah i know
people that chill with snitches and go
well
you ain't telling me yeah that type of
[__] you're drunk dealers
when do you think it's coming for you
man it's gonna happen
i i promise it's ha he's gonna play you
people don't understand ah man i hate
talking about drug [__]
i don't i don't i just hate thinking
about all the [__] that goes with it
yeah oh god but um
i don't remember how we got into that i
think i'm gonna say that that's gonna be
a t-shirt
how the [__] do we start talking about
that that's gonna be a shirt
how the [__] did we start talking about
that that's the point of the podcast
though
it is dude because it's about drugs uh
that's the dea story guys that's my dea
story
thank you for listening to that part on
to another completely unrelated topic
drugs it literally says
on my notes drugs
drugs and then it says dot dot dot
the first time i ever smoked meth
nothing like a good drug convo after a
long drug convo
yep but this one will be a little better
it'll be faster okay
i'm just gonna tell you guys real quick
i'll give you the gist
mercedes it's it's full of meth right
we've talked about that before on the
first episode i think we touched on that
yeah we touched on that a little bit
ah oh you ready
so the first time i smoked meth i was
[Music]
14 or 15. i can't remember exactly the
age now because
if it was in september i was 15. i was
probably 15. here we go
i used to hang out my friend nathan
nathan gomez his mom was a paramedic
he she was a single mom single child
well not a single child but his sister
didn't live there
so he has an apartment right by the
college in between the college and the
high school
his mom does two days on paramedics for
some reason they work for 48 hours
shifts sometimes
she'd be gone for two solid days guys
and all she did was
buy [__] massive amounts of food
because nathan you eat so much
you're he was a big dude you eat so much
where in reality
eight of his friends are demolishing
[__] drunk as [__]
every saturday and sun or every friday
and saturday so
that's why the food was always gone
so nathan gomez man we'd go to his house
every friday night we'd sleep there
right we'd sleep there and sleep there
saturday
and every time his mom was coming home
sometimes she'd come home the next
morning so we had to be out there by six
we'd clean the entire house spotless
and we'd be out of there at six we'd
walk to mcdonald's
or burger king whichever was open at
that time and we'd go in there and
sleep in the [__] booths we'd order a
drink
we all who wants to power it excuse me
we get a powerade for five people one
cup
ordered like two breakfast sandwiches
like technically we're customers
and we'd pass the [__] out in the booths
ev we did that for two
years like two years straight every
weekend
imagine a little drunk crew of friends
little [__] high schoolers
every morning or every weekend morning
sometimes only on sunday because his mom
like i said sometimes she'd be 48 hours
or she'd sleep at the place i don't know
i just know she didn't come back
and we'd clean the house spotless
spotless every time
and then yeah that was our routine so my
routine i'm there at nathan's
every [__] weekend every weekend
and we smoke and drink so i'm shitfaced
drunk
i'm shith drunk off gin first time i
ever drunk chin my friend
first time i ever drank gin me and my
friend ramon got a
taxi first time i ever bought a taxi
also
every time first time i ever got a taxi
got a taxi and me and ramon took it
because he lists one block away from me
my grandpa's on the other side of town
and we go
oh my god and we [__]
get dropped off right by nathan's and he
has a fifth of gin
and clear kool-aid mix do you remember
clear kool-aid it was called the mystery
flavor
but it was clear it was like transparent
it didn't have a color
but it's called the mystery flavors a
white pack he had a pack of those like a
stack
and jen he goes bro here's the chaser go
[__] smart
so we go into nathan's nathan at that
point when we started having the
of the older kids over uh sam would come
over john would come over there were
older kids
nathan was trying to be cool with them
and [__] even though i thought they were
kind of douche bags
at the time they ended up being cool but
they were kind of douchey and
that's it we chill there but you know
when you have your chill spot with your
friends
that's your chill spot and then these
older guys come in you like
look at the [__] out of here you know
how you feel like don't try to be cool
[__] this is our spot
i clean this house every weekend not you
that's how i felt
and we're there it's like a kind of a
party there's like [__] a bunch of
different girls there i'm like there's
never girls here what the [__] kind of
weekend is this nice
and we're sitting in nathan's kitchen
i'm sitting right between the cabinet
here's the sink i'm sitting on the cab
on the counter like i always say i sat
right there
when we were chilling in the kitchen but
we didn't anyway anyway
we're there romaine ramon are taking
giant giant shrimp we used to call them
king cups
here's a red line a red solo cup go here
to liquor a little more than halfway of
liquor and the rest we'd mix
so it was our mixed drink and you better
not put less than half of that liquid
it's
absurd don't drink like that was stupid
anyway i'm drinking i drink like three
of those i am [__] face drunk
right i smoke weed i have some weed in
my pocket i go in nathan's backyard
which is apartment building so it's a
little square concrete
block with a little fence around it you
know a regular apartment
i go back there there's a guy named ryan
not my friend ryan
uh white dude ryan mexican ryan i've
known him since tanaya
since middle school there's this girl
named jennifer i won't say her last name
[__] you jennifer damn it this girl
named jennifer they're smoking out of a
weed pipe
a regular ass weed pipe right like
you know it's night it's dark i'm [__]
up the light's not on outside we're kids
having a party the light's off we're in
an apartment we're trying to stay quiet
so we're just
they're packing bowls or whatever i come
out their [__] face i got weed in my
pocket i'm like yo let me hit that
and ryan's like big-ass t looking at me
he's all [__] up i look at jennifer
i'm like
let me hit that i got weed in my pocket
i'm not trying to like just freeload off
your [__] let me pack a bowl
and she goes hit this but she'll but
it's a cabbie you guys have heard the
story before
if you heard story time she goes but
it's a cabbie and i'm like i don't
[__] know what that means [__] but
i'm not gonna go what's that
look like a dummy i'm like mitch what
the [__] does that mean give me that
weed pipe
and i [__] i roast it i roast the
[__] out of the whole bowl
and as i'm hitting she goes whoa calm
down and in my head
i do this [__] but in my head i'm like
[__] you [__] i know how to smoke weed
like
like on some friday [__] calm down
smokey that's basically what happened to
me
i'm hitting this ball and i'm
i'm hitting it and ryan looks at her
like damn and i'm like yo you guys don't
smoke weed what the [__]
why am i holding my breath what the [__]
am i doing i'm over holding my breath
[__] anyway i'm holding my breath with
the weed smoke in
and i let it out and as i let it out i
taste something different
i know it's not something else like yo
what is this and i'm blowing the smoke
out and she goes
it's got crystal dude that's how i've
heard it it's drawing
chris honored chris if you don't know
what that means means crystal meth she
goes it's got chris it's a cabbie
as i let the smoke out i go what the
[__]
i got pissed check i [__] told you
it's a cab you guys how do i know what
the [__] that means
if you don't smoke crystal meth
why would you know the slang terms that
chris heads use
you just weren't cool enough it wasn't
cool enough not cool enough
that's how i felt and um i let the smoke
out
[Music]
and i look at him i go what the [__] i
told you as a cabbie that whole thing
happens
and ryan starts dying laughing like he
was
laughing and i didn't i didn't think it
was funny
i didn't think that was funny they keep
smoking it
i just see the lighter spark up and i
walk right back in the house and i'm
thinking
you can put chris on top of weed i
didn't know you could do that i thought
you had to hit in a pookie
for everyone out there has never smoked
chris you can smoke chris in a weed pipe
let me just [__] tell you that [__]
right now
first time i ever smoked chris i don't
know if it hit me hard
but it touched it touched my brain i'ma
tell you that right now because
i don't know if it burns right in a weed
or with weed
but it affected me i'm gonna tell you
that my little ass brain
it popped me in the head walked back
into the kitchen
and i couldn't stop moving my body i
really didn't like the feeling
it felt like my my brain was having a
conversation and my body was doing some
other [__] like my brain was talking to
myself
but my body was doing [__] that i didn't
ask it to do does that make sense like i
felt you ever see people like
just itch and move just like [__] that's
because it's crystal meth in their body
crystal meth is a [__] workout
machine and all it does is make your
body just slightly move
and i swear i felt like i couldn't stop
and then my skin started feeling itchy
like my back started feeling itchy my
[__] head i was just like
ugh this is why i see tweakers itching
so i felt really itchy like right do
right now tweaking
and um
i just wouldn't stop moving i smoked
like 68 cigarettes back to back
and then i projectile threw up all over
nate's
backyard area while he was trying to
bang a girl and i had to
walk through the room to get to the
backyard
so every time i walk through i go i'm
sorry i'm sorry and they
after the fourth time i walked through
there they were just both cracking up
weren't even trying to bang each other
anymore
nathan and that girl was dying laughing
at me
because i didn't know they could hear me
throwing up i would walk toward the
backyard and close the door
and i'd throw up everywhere so i'd walk
back in trying to play it off
and i'd go and i was getting pictures of
water in a [__]
uh water like a juice picture i was
getting water and
walking it remember it's a dark room
you're trying to bang that girl so i'm
walking through hey man just gonna go in
the backyard and i was
trying to wash the [__] puke down
that would go out of the you know
because there's a little
you know on apartments right it's the
concrete slab the fence and there's like
a little gap in the fence all apartments
man there's a little gap in that
[__] fence so i'm trying to
wash the puke out without nathan
come on man you're throwing up what the
i didn't want him to get mad plus i was
tripping i was paranoid so i was like
extra thinking about it i took like my
third or fourth trip they started
busting the [__] up laughing
and as i'm walking back the last time he
goes thomas i can see the picture of
water bro we heard you throwing up i go
[__]
you for real you heard me why was i
sneaking this whole [__] time i was
trying to be like
no no i'm just catching some air you
know
and i was trying and the next day he
said i didn't do a good job at all he's
like bro i went out there and there's
throw up everywhere still all she did
was like
push it around i didn't get it anyway
it's pitch black out there
i don't [__] know what's going on
just i just know i threw up and i'm
trying my best
that was my night first time i ever
smoked crystal meth first time i ever
smoked i think that's the only time i
smoked chris
hmm secondhand crystal smoke
that's different but that's the only
time i ever smoked chris
is there a part of smoking chris that's
actually enjoyable for people that has
to be right there there has to be there
has to be i think it's
um okay so i've snorted it
does nothing to you well at least my
body it did nothing
it sucked i hated it
and all it did is feel like i snorted a
bunch of glass shards and it just got
stuck in my [__] brain that's why i
have a sinus infection today
because the crystal meth i started when
i was 16
is stuck in my nasal cast expiring
it's expired that's the only reason i
have insomnia is because i have chris
stuck in my nasal cavities
we're here to talk about life problems
drugs accomplishments
everything in between everything the
first time i smoke meth
all right uh let's get back on my
schedule
funny story the only interaction i ever
had with
meth was that i found out our daughter's
babysitter smoked meth your daughter's
babysitter had a job
uh as our babysitter i know that's what
i'm saying that that first thing is
astonishing [__] out of him she was
she young our friend yeah but then was
that one
buffalo yeah wait you found out
she's a raging method you couldn't tell
[__]
i think it might have seamlessly
happened around the same time
nothing seamless happens it goes from
normal to animal from [__] muppets
bro
yeah all right yep it kind of was like
that yeah it did kind of snowball
yeah how'd you find out how did you find
out was she
high one day you couldn't
i'm trying to think how we really found
i remember there was like i'm like okay
i got a nanny cam this bro something's
going on
it's like you say it i found out my
babysitter was really fat the other day
yo you couldn't tell that [__]
was fat it's obvious
that's a good point yeah yeah i don't
know what the [__] was wrong with me but
somehow it came to be known that you'd
have enough mexican
buffalo crackheads yeah do you guys have
meth on the east coast
or is it crank yeah [__] i i couldn't
tell you crack
probably more crack huh crack is
definitely a thing yeah for sure i mean
i don't know about anymore when i was
there it was definitely a thing
but yeah math and all that i never had
any experiences with that [__]
yeah cause you were smart you're over
there dunking on [__]
maybe if i were to smoke math
it doesn't help your athletic athletics
at all i promise bro it does not
but it does make you fight forever ask
the same
person 86 times for a dollar and it'll
it'll
it'll definitely make you sell [__] make
your parents disappointed but still take
care of your ass
uh what else does meth do i don't know
get your kids taken away and then you
get them back at 14 when i'm clean i'm a
mom
i'm going to be a nurse assistant
i'm sorry for all 92 percent of people i
just described
they all have a rose tattoo on their
wrist
oh [__] oh no how many people just
looked down and went [__] you
the buffalo equivalent of that is a 14
year old girl
with a stroller and she's got spongebob
pajama pants on
and there's two kids in the stroller but
she's 15. and she's got some
you know greasy yeah that's yeah not
quite as dramatic but
no that's bad i i it sucks man i do i do
feel bad for those young ass moms
because they don't realize what they
just
did your life is now their life
you haven't lived yet you're gonna be
real regretful
real bitter around 26 when those kids
are getting into high school
i felt like you know having a kid at a
young age i felt like how old were you
believed like
uh i think let me see here right i was
21.
so it felt relieved why because i knew
that it was going to like
force me to grow into a into a
meaningful path that's cool most people
think of that as the opposite
oh damn now i got to [__] do what i
want to do before this kid gets old
no i'm a piece of [__] yeah
yo bad parents i hate them more some bad
weed man
well they're the cause of everything
that's wrong with the world that's a
hundred percent
that kid at school that's a piece of
[__] he's gonna be a dad one day
let's hope he changes that's how i feel
like dude
there's a lot of people i know that go
you're a [__] dad not not now
uh that people i know in l.a but back
home like you're a dad now
i remember we were snorting [__] meth
off your notebook
what the [__] going on
remember when we peed on that wall we
were faded like
you're a dad i always say every
[__] that's ever fought on
worldstar is probably a dad you guys got
to remember these terrible things
every ignorant [__] that's ever
fought on a youtube compilation is going
to have a child one day
lots of them you know what i'm saying
like it's idiocracy
all over again have you ever seen the
movie idiocracy
no you go way deeper with the
oh no no you are gonna really love this
movie marty idiocracy if you guys
haven't seen it sorry
idiocracy is a movie about the future
right but a guy from present day gets
travels to the future and everyone's
[__]
stupid everyone that's the president
terry crews is the president of the
united states
looking like that that's not that far
off impossible it's amazing
though like he looks tight but it's like
when the way they introduced justin long
as a doctor
yeah your brain is just it's all stupid
and [__] as you're smoking a joy
i'm a doctor yo go home and watch
idiocracy
that's the white house but that [__]
would look like the [__] in january
yeah that's i know oh they have oh we
can't be
all right this is getting too deep
because i'm
in too deep was that some 41
in too deep simon's over here asking
like eight different questions but
siri say siri
some 41 into yup there he is
a is i remember them
about [__] married to avril lavigne
all those night like the avril lavigne's
the atlantis morrissettes the
like that old 90s [__]
how did it just disappear though where
did the internet singers go i mean no no
they didn't go anywhere there was just
900 other really good singers introduced
from the internet
and your phone and you get to see more
how many new rappers are there that
don't resonate but they were popping
probably a lot think about it how many
rappers pop out you go oh he got a big
song he'll be gone in exactly a month
it's sad bro people are too used to she
used to [__] popping
who's the next pop and artist and it
just disappears which takes me directly
into my next my next
[__] comment marty
what do you think about the state of rap
music today
as an artist as a person that used to
make music
what do you think the state of rapid it
could be underground it could be
commercial but what do you think
what do you think about i want to know
your opinion as not as marty
as somebody that's that used to do music
like somebody that was actively
making songs yeah i think it's it's at a
point now where it's like the artist can
be more in control
like as far as
vertically kind of owning everything
that you need to do to be able to put it
out and start making money
if if you have the personality to back
it up because going and having a bunch
of bodies of
great music really isn't enough it has
to be like anymore
yeah that what happened in this past
year with like zelda and everybody
blowing up out of buffalo like
the world to me because not only was it
something coming out of buffalo it
showed
everybody in buffalo that it is possible
and [__] can be done
but they were bringing it back to more
of an authentic hip-hop where they
the first time i heard i was like yo how
old is this song mm-hmm i'm like yeah
this
is some straight throwback dope [__] and
then he started saying certain thing i'm
like
this is new yeah any time somebody's
really getting something off their chest
like that
and it's unique and that the combination
of the production
with with that artist really getting it
off their chest and they mean what
they're saying
you just can't to me that's can't deny
it yeah it is
it's not a such a and what i i know
personally about those dudes they were
at it
way before i was even like benny in them
he was damn near a legend back in 2004
when i was just starting to go into
studios and stuff like he was
that goes to show how long it really
takes to make something like this happen
something a lot with longevity takes
so well everybody says it takes 10 years
to pop bro this is our 10th year
it takes 10 years to know what you're
doing i feel like no it's our ninth year
sorry but
still it takes so [__] long to do
[__] when you're doing it for yourself
yeah
yeah it takes a lot i could have took
that i could have took that [__]
money when i
it's a long story but somebody tried to
buy push trees into
2017 and i didn't take the money because
i knew what we're going to do
and i thought it was fake also and then
i found out it was not fake at all
but they offered me 10 mil when i had no
money whatsoever and i was broke as [__]
i still broke [__] but you know what i'm
saying
when i was struggling hard and i
remember i turned it down when i was
i needed it and i thought like nah this
is going to be way bigger than
the [__] selling it now [__] you
and uh that's a bold move sir no i know
i know
i know and i also told him to suck my
dick you must have really thought it was
fake
i didn't think he was and then i
financed the [__]
air of the company
i told him to suck my dick i said yo
tell him to suck my dick
i'm such an [__] i'm super polite but
man at certain times i was just kidding
i thought it was funny
hey yo what's up my dick i thought it
was funny thing to say
it sounds funny to me still it's like
you know what when i always
you know when i drag things out hey yo
you know what i always
i'm mimicking in my head and i the
reason i do that
it's when king's a comedy when said
you're the entertainer's all i can't be
calling no grown man delicious
he's all hey yo
look delicious that's how i always think
about that
cedric the dude ass is stuck in my head
every time i say that [__]
god when he fell trying to try to [__]
around on stage and he hurt his hip
god i remember that i i'm gonna go home
watch king's comedy that's just so i
just watched it
recently dan that that's just funny um
but sorry damn see this rants i'm gonna
call if we
strain [__] rant og because jesus
this [__] just gots me talking about
nothing but um
i'm glad you guys are still here i
didn't realize it's been [__] turning
down the 10 million
deal is not nothing especially if people
didn't know about that [__] well
it's from a big company so i don't i i
could do a story time on it but it's
gonna i'm gonna have to be so
vague vague they might
be in this field of work like i can't
it's i can't
be i can't tell a story can tell a full
story so you know i can
i can tell the full story don't want to
don't want to put that on me because for
about a year after that
there was some blatant obvious [__]
these people were doing to me
they were upset that i yelled
this is what happened i'll tell you what
happened this guy this [__] guy
this guy used to be friends with like i
said i love people of death and they
[__] me over i can't [__] with them they
just can't trust them
love this guy to death this [__]
i'm just at his house
right i'm at his house i'm on my phone
i'm high i'm just on my phone i know he
knows the owners of this very
very large company i know that he know
he knows a bunch of rich ass
millionaire [__] i know he knows them
i know they're from the same town that
we're in right now
but i'm just on my phone hi right
i'm in the i'm just sitting there he
walks in like this
on the phone i don't know why i grab
this just do my hand if he walks in on
the phone
like this i'm you're the camera right
you guys are me
i'm the [__] dumbass friend walks in
hey just like that with the phone goes
hey it says some super important [__]
while like this
so automatically [__] you this ain't no
serious professional [__] you're not
going to go
hey let me check [__] no he can still
hear you
this is not serious oh damn it spit this
is not serious
so he goes hey so-and-so says um
they want to buy your company like oh
what they go so-and-so is on the phone
i'm not gonna say the company goes
so-and-so's on the phone and says they
wanna buy push trees right now flat out
and i go okay i'm good
and he gets on the phone like this he's
like well he's not really up to it blah
blah blah
and he goes oh okay hold up i'm like
this is the [__] my friend's [__]
with me
we're smoking weed at his house i know
he's got this
i know we're not just like in a garage
red is hot yeah i mean
but i know he knows these people i know
that he knows a lot of people
i'll take it serious and he goes they
say they'll give you 10 million dollars
and i go what he goes they said they'll
give you 10 mil right now for push trees
you sign everything over
and i go tell him to suck my dick
i yelled that [__] out with like oh
i [__] screamed sung that [__]
if he could hear him talking with the
phone on his chest
he could definitely hear tell him to
suck my
dick but if you got 10 million dollars
to offer
and some little [__] piece of [__]
high-ass kid that you guys know is
popping on the internet
his little company that is doing well
and you could buy it
and if you offer him 10 million dollars
to a broke-ass kid and he tells you suck
my dick
you're gonna be upset i don't care right
now no matter who you are you're gonna
go what the [__]
so that's what happened he walks away he
goes like this
as i say suck my dick and he goes
like covers the phone more and i'm like
wait wait is that real
nah and he walks out the room i'm on my
phone
three minutes later he comes in mad he
comes in upset
what the [__] i'm like what the [__]
because i'm over here like i paid no
mind imagine your friend does that to
you right now
you're not gonna pay that no attention
he goes foo that was so-and-so on the
phone like yeah
right [__] he goes thomas
that was the owner of so-and-so
and you just said suck my tell him to
suck my dick
and i go bro that was not real for 30
minutes straight we're going back and
forth that was not that wasn't real
and ass this beats into my head that it
was real
i just crumbled i just told i just told
the owner of this company to suck my
dick
i would have at least considered it like
yo
10 mil but can i keep like 20 of this
company can i have some royalties
and i would have sold that [__] right
then and there if i knew the 10 mil was
real
nah i know i wouldn't know if i probably
wouldn't have no i wouldn't have but
still
i might have considered like y'all give
you 40 if you give me like 5 million
dollars
30 percent 5 million you know what i
mean because at that time that would
have been bomb
right five million you're broken merced
and he's just telling me and pushing it
into my face like
that was real i'm like no now you're a
liar
and as i come to the conclusion that
he's serious i look in and go bro
what happened after i said that he goes
he was [__] pissed
he heard me go of course he hurt you you
[__] screamed
like oh my god oh my god oh wait we're
two and a half hours in
i can i could i gotta drink this water
sorry my throat is
spongebob
damn my throat is on fire
okay so after i realized it's real i
crumbled to the ground
and realized not because the money
because i realized that i just
was super super rude to this man that
i've never met
the company of i'm a fan of i respect
this person
and i just told him to suck my dick as
he offered me 10 million [__] dollars
for my little ass company on instagram
this is back when we were not popping
hard as [__] man we were doing great
but we were not doing like we are now
not even a fraction
well obviously yeah fraction but a small
fraction
and uh that was the time that happened
it came back to bite me real hard i
won't get into specifics because then
people that are smart
are going to go hey is it this company
because that's exactly the time they
started doing that
anyway they started a nevermind i'll
sleep at that
i got into a bunch of altercations of
these guys
in person one time and i was gonna beat
the [__]
out of three of these people i don't
think they realized
that i'm
i am not saying i'm a tough guy at all
in any way
but i would have [__] all three of
those fools up and just
just stomped him into oblivion i was
so upset i can't get into it this
something happened one time and they
were super
[__] rude and mean to me once and
then they try to punk me
it didn't work
i don't know man i've been punked i've
been surrounded by more people than that
yeah we'll just leave it at that it was
funny it was leaving it was funny anyway
makes me think of that scene in juice
where they they press tupac up against
the wall and he spits on their face and
all that [__]
that's not what i did whatever i stood
there staring i'm like
oh [__] can you fight all of you right
like all these cameras right now i'll
fight all of you
that's exactly how i felt and um
that's how that happened but that's a
whole other story maybe one day we'll be
able to get fully into it
that'd be bomb how about this ready guys
i'll make you a promise
the day we can figure out not getting
deleted off the internet every five
seconds i'll tell the full story
because i always have the feeling that
they're the ones paying to shut me down
because they got dumb [__] [__] you
money
no they do i i can tell
yeah they do they want to go hey
instagram
shut this kid's page off he's breaking
the [__] rules anyway
all right we'll do it thanks for the
money and then just do it every couple
months
[Laughter]
welcome uh how do we get into that story
meth i think we're smoking meth we're
smoking meth that we got in that story
um okay i'm gonna skip a couple of these
things
you know what no no i'm not people are
gonna get set everyone that likes these
super long ones
you're welcome because this one's about
to get a little bit longer are you ready
you ready marty i'm gonna ask you a
question all right
were you a nickelodeon kid or cartoon
network kid
or or neither were your nick and knight
no i was absolutely nickelodeon
nice good [__] i knew that i knew i
liked you
cartoon network's cool for the cow and
chicken and the [__]
dexter's lab and then i gotta bounce
yeah i don't know about any of that [__]
it's just oh
dexter's lab was alternate angry beavers
i think that was nickelodeon i don't
[__] know but i know dexter's lab was
cartoon network and i [__] with
dexter's lab
heavy um nickelodeon
were you more of the cartoons or like
the alex mack and all that type of [__]
i mean i was i was big into the tgi
friday that was my [__]
heavy duty with the urkel the
step-by-step all that you know wait
urkel was on nico oh nick knight yeah
yeah yeah
but what i do want to say is that i am
somewhat legendary because i did grow up
out you know
from a kid that grew up on the og ninja
turtles to grow up and actually marry
april neil
[Laughter]
every time we go to use her debit card
or anything
give it to me casey jones son
yo this person i am legendary
i was literally thinking where the [__]
is marty going with this i
am legend marty just snapped guys
it's been too long and marty went
[__] he went psych humble brag here
guys but yeah but that's true
that's really i didn't think about it
either [__] marty married
april o'neil that's really funny yeah i
made her april o'neil
it was i bestowed that upon her now
forevermore she's the coolest person
whenever she shows her id they go
cowabunga
like you know what i'm gonna start
saying i'm gonna start quoting the wrong
movie
yo how sick would that be to start
quoting the wrong [__] movies
you're gonna go for a lot of people's
heads people don't know movies like you
they just people are relying you know
what they're gonna be like yeah i love
them like
[__] that was a different movie all
right never mind i'm not gonna do this
that's dumb never mind now i'm just
gonna see i'm just that's just called
testing people
that's a good question for the guests
though like start rattling off
the everybody was either a nickelodeon
or whatever kid nickelodeon kinder
cartoon working man for real i was
nickelodeon all
[__] day i watched rugrats a lot and
i also i always thought
what bad parents those
babies with no shoes on were walking
the earth didn't give he had a [__]
scrooge
oh that's marty marty's tommy pickles
walking around the [__] screwdriver
in his pocket
this this [__] was fake stuff in
his diaper with a screwdriver
tommy and my name is thomas i thought he
was the coolest uh
chucky he's a little [__] but he's
really cool as a little baby if
chucky was a real baby that is the
coolest looking little kid
red hair and just [__] like dreads he
was tight as
[__] i like him uh-huh i like him but i
was a rugrats kid
i could do the [__] doug funny for
some reason have you done it
[__] porkchop you know i was
into doug
we tried to watch the other day not
nearly as fun as an adult doesn't hold
out
no i was so bored a lot of so bad
a lot of those shows still my kids still
are on the 90 [__] heavy duty
i'll watch it but i was not like whoa
anymore roger every time he comes out
guitar and [__] i just brought back
dinosaurs remember oh we're just talking
about it mama
uh who who was it that looks like baby
sinclair
we were watching a documentary i go damn
that guy looks like baby sinclair from
dinosaurs
and then the oh we're watching crack the
crack documentary and the oh
the old lady looked like the grandma
from dinosaurs
yo who looked like baby from dining i
don't know we just watched a dog
community that [__] looked
straight up by baby sinclair
my homie ratchet man he's hella into uh
dinosaurs the show
and he looks just like the baby not the
mama [__]
oh that was my [__] as a kid i was a
child too
so i was really i was heavy into that i
was in the step by step
not not as much as full house i [__]
with full house heavy yeah of course but
my ultimate
was family matters mm-hmm yeah of course
um stephan arkell
is the epitome of cool steve urkel
is the [__] and laura is a [__]
for playing his ass so [__] hard dude
she played him so [__] hard oh you
took your glasses off
i [__] with you [__] you laura what if i
get contacts as steve
you [__] that's what i never got as a
kid i always thought
is that a different actor because as a
kid i didn't know
yo that's jaleel white still that was
mind-blowing
they [__] me up because then i thought
julia white's cool in real life and he
plays a nerd
and that's my mind just you know what
else blew my mind when steve urkel
walked into the full house house
remember that cross episode and steve
rickle walked in go get
the [__] out of here this is
wild it's like the first time i mixed
weed and alcohol as a kid like
you could put them together
yo um quick story i was at a weed
convention
yeah oh man you know john stamos if i
ever meet you i'm gonna [__] chest
bump and high-five your ass
because you are the coolest yo john
stamos is cool he's
he's cool to me he's just as cool as
as [__] mario lopez mario lopez is
[__] awesome
he wasn't the best host at the tyson
thing because it was kind of a weed
related thing yeah no mario lopez grew
up with john stamos on his wall what are
we talking about
hey hey hey hey that might be true
uncle jesse's cooler yeah that's what
i'm talking about mario
john stamos i mean uncle jesse i know
but
all right look at it you mean in the
show i [__] with mario lopez
right now because it's like you
dedicated ass
old man are still in shape yeah you are
rock the [__] out and you're old
like maybe i'll just be fat till i get
old and i go yo remember tommy just got
[__]
ripped at 40.
could you imagine like being fat forever
like hey when i want to start aging i'm
going to get in shape
that's hilarious but that's that's mario
lopez man anyway
john's name is white cooler for sure
yeah it's just uncle jesse they have
come on man what do you want me to say i
love
full house mario's there to look cool
jesse yes to act
cool lamar lopez man i don't know
[__] with him heavy i [__] with him
heavily there's not many mexican
[__] on the on the tv
and he's still there man he's still
there killing it while every other
[__] from saved by the bell
is not every other person in that fight
what oh don't be saying that [__]
i'm just saying dustin diamond man
that's so sad he just died that's not
what i was saying
i love screech i would never say
anything bad about screech
i just forgot this creature doing [__]
that's what he meant my bad
yeah zack morris they're not doing [__]
but i'm saying like they're not
hosting mike tyson's [__]
boxing ring he's like the mexican ryan
seacrest
mario's out there
am i wrong i don't know that much about
tv but no i just
i've never been so happy with the
comparison you just gave me
because now i do have something to
compare it to like you are the mexican
ryan see chris
i love you marty thank you so much
i love comparisons and references and
that's the best reference you can give
mario lopez
okay he's the mexican riot secrets i
don't know [__] about either of these
people so i'm gonna no
[__] that ryan see chris is the white
mario lopez there you go okay i feel
better about that
mario lopez is a g if you've been around
since the early 90s yeah you
yeah you get mentioned before ryan
seacrest yeah dude um
yeah we got into this about nickelodeon
or cartoon network see this
rant city i'm gonna make sure this is
rant city it's gonna be bomb
all right i'm gonna light this last
little joint we are getting deep into
this podcast guys thank you for sticking
around
i did not think this was going to go
that long but i'm going to
close this out we'll not fully close
this out let me bring up my last little
piece of my notes
damn i love having notes so [__] much
better than trying to remember [__]
because it doesn't work you guys ready
here's a segment called uh
uh well here's the thing i'm gonna start
calling now that's dope
every time i see some baller [__] on the
internet where it makes you stop going
now that's [__] dope
that's what this segment's gonna be
about are you ready
something i just found out this morning
and it really
really made me happy there is a new
mortal kombat movie coming out guys
if you're a fan of the first two mortal
kombats well if you're a fan of the
first one and you're okay with the
second one
like i am it's coming look at that oh
look at that ad
oh that's bomb as [__] guys i just
if you have time after this podcast
go watch the mortal kombat trailer it's
on
[__] believable i can't wait i
got kung lao in that [__] i
can't wait dude it's gonna be
so sick this is uh this is dope as [__]
it just reminds me of being a kid i
played mortal kombat on the [__] 25
cent
arcade [__] at the boys and girls club
right where that old man was touching
his dick all the time
and uh i got we called the cops on him
and they gave me a
sticker sheriff's deputy sticker a cop
game though thank you
patrol pretty much man and foul patrol
this [__] old mex can just touch his
dick and his pants and just stand at the
[__]
the [__] slides or next to the
playground
i remember i told my mom i'm calling the
cops the cops came and told him to leave
he was there every day he was a weird
[__] man
anyway that's where i started playing
mortal kombat right behind the dick
touching
in the boys and girls club right there
on sixth and yeah
more combat new versions coming out
mortal kombat one the first one also it
reminds me is being really
hot and like sticky from eating fruit
and juices that my grandma graces when i
used to run around with [__]
you know what i mean as a kid when you
run around dirty as [__] i would just
sit and watch like mortal kombat 1.
but oh scorpion and we go back and run
around and [__]
man a new one's coming and there's
[__] just graphics and technology and
[__] can edit better
oh it's going to be so johnny did you
play shaq back in the day
a shack fool what's that it was like
mortal kombat but it was shaq
shaquille o'neal yeah no or street is
that real
yeah it was actually one of my favorite
games for uh chris marty's just having a
[__]
allergic reaction to all the smoke in
the air just like remember
remembering [__] that never happened oh
[__] it happened this is
real shaq foo was the [__]
he totally bit more he completely bit it
it's dead on the same [__] wait he was
doing this before
he quit the nba oh yeah we're talking
this is not this is like shazam [__]
yeah
shazam was a bad movie but when as a kid
when i was hella hungry all the time
i loved shazam when you made it rain
hamburgers and pizzas and [__] i always
thought man one day i'm gonna find a
genie i'm gonna ask for help
see that's why i joined the asthma club
oh dude i was a kid i'm like yo there's
gotta be something
more to this
hey i'm gonna get some pizza after this
for i know i got some juice to drink
damn it
i'm almost done with this juice cleanse
my head hurts okay also another
uh part on the segment of now that's
dope did you know for those of you that
i'm about to blow your [__] minds and
the other people are gonna go yeah
you're late as [__]
super nintendo world you guys ready for
that
super nintendo world opens in japan this
month
you can go to super nintendo world like
you go to studios of universal or
[__] disneyland look
yes thank you bring it up on this thing
that's real that looks like animation
no i don't know about that that looks
fake
looks like a minecraft world but and
like i mean
no i watched the owner do the walk
through on youtube there's a video of
the owner walking through on youtube
marty if you can find it
guys it's interactive
the entire world is interactive you can
make it
do [__] you can make the mushroom grow
or you can make the [__]
plant uh like the what are they called
venus fly traps bite you and [__]
oh here we go he's bringing it up on the
screen damn two
ads back to back twice goddamn can we
get jesus yeah
follow your [__] press and like
on these youtube videos thank you
for yeah look at look at him
he looks so nice see that's the vibe i
get hey you got a dollar like i do
that's from the fiverr yeah yeah right
you're really nice man look oh
look at the mountains behind it man
that's pretty sick
i like how it's like they got like the
depths going on with the little
you know what else they do guys i
watched it for those of you that not
gonna watch it
there's a room after you hit it and get
the mushroom to get bigger the room that
you walk in starts to get smaller
so you're bigger mario well yeah
look at the food oh my god
yo it makes me feel like a little kid
look at him even he's like i know
i know bow to me look at this [__]
it's [__] incredible dude man they
probably started putting 10 billion
dollars into this yeah
it probably cost billions of dollars for
sure just wanders around here
by himself on a [__] skateboard he
just skates the park
every day it's opening this month i had
to bring it up because it's [__] dope
and that finishes a segment of no that's
dope
if you guys have any things you see
around shoot them our way hit us up on
instagram
we're gonna make a twitter so hit us up
on twitter also
the links are always in the description
the links are always in the youtube
description too
apple podcast google podcast um amazon
music spotify all that stuff
dope as usual check it out all right man
that was it
we are at oh my god almost three hours
in wow by myself that is a rant
that is a [__] rant whoa
now that's that's the podcast that's the
podcast vibes when you're just chilling
and just
that's just that's right hours bro i
just looked and it was at 55 minutes
all right that's what that wee will do
to you man
i guess well i mean i guess not i don't
ever do this i smoke every day
sorry but i'm taking another drink in
this [__] water
less weed than the last couple podcasts
i was noticing in that joshua footage
i'm like he's in a [__]
uh cumulonimbus cloud this whole episode
you just said a style cloud of type of
clouds
yeah yeah i missed uh long division day
and cloud day because i don't know what
[__] cloud that is
one of the fans in the comments was like
thomas treats his joints like an incense
because this is what happens oh let me
explain that to you guys real quick the
reason i'm sitting here lighting this
like this
is because when i take [__] huge rips
and [__] i cough
and i don't want to cough into the mic
[__] driving to work going
am i just listening to a [__]
cough i have to go to work he's just
getting high they're gonna be pissed
i don't wanna be just coughing into your
ear could you imagine driving you just
here
not fun not how would you did you like
that
did you like that fake cough because it
could be real and nobody wants that
so i learned when i interviewed tommy
chong last year
when i felt so stupid i was coughing so
violently because i was ripping and i
wrote an eighth joint i was ripping it
while he was talking
and he stopped what he was doing he goes
bro you got to get that cough looked at
and i looked in and go i'm sorry tommy
i'm [__] up you right you're talking
like i felt so bad like i'm so sorry so
that's why i try not to rip the joint
too much when i'm
talking and if i'm by myself there's
nobody
else that i was conversating with as a
guest
to keep up with the talking so it's just
hey
excuse me so that's why i
keep lighting it oh i keep lighting it
because if not it's gonna burn crooked
plus i'm kind of spacing out it's the
same thing as doing this
people [__] around it's i don't know
it's just a [__] habit
the reason i do that is to keep it
burning right so
for everyone asking in the comments yes
that's exactly why i do that and the
reason i don't rip it back to back when
people are talking
because i hate having to cough over
people talking it's super rude
to try to hold back or cough oh have you
i've tried to hold back many costs when
people are talking
that's called like breaking a rib yeah
i've done that filming your videos
there you go oh yeah i always think
about that like you get
hot boxed in this room just breathing a
secondhand smoke the last video i
sorry charlie i boxed charlie and his
new assistant
first day on the job he was in the same
box room i was filming a
bong rip video so he's sitting there
just catching my clouds and he's like
this
with the camera it's like yeah yeah
with the [__] ronin the gimbal and
[__] he's like
yeah i'm gonna blow it right at your
face all right
i felt so bad you got to be a unique
camera man to hang on the dope as yellow
shoes
for you got to be able to stand up for a
long time too
while being [__] up i try not to marty
you don't ever smoke when we film [__]
you wait till right after the second
we're done marty likes to join well i
learned i learned those first couple
shoots i'm gonna
i'm gonna hit this [__] vapen and
then hold back a cough for the next 20
minutes
[Laughter]
well that's the way it works yeah that's
how we do it over production value folks
yep uh like yeah for all these videos
you see these little simple
reviews yesterday we took what was it
eight hours to film one ten minute video
because the b-roll and the lighting and
all this [__] so yeah we put some time
into this
thank you guys so much for watching we
put so much time marty's editing these
and he's putting in days of work on
these edits because we could
guys we could do two podcasts a week but
then i mean the quality of the video
goes down
and that's not what we're about we want
it to be cool we want to look sick as
[__]
that's what we have so many different
angles we have so much going on it's why
we
built a set in the warehouse because we
want to look cool we want it to be more
than just like uh
hey by the way i have followers here's a
sheet behind me
i'm going to talk to you like like and
subscribe like
that could work but also this is
something we wanted
for the long haul me and marty are here
to do this [__] for real
and it's fun it's fun guys and you know
what something crazy
we're about to get some sponsors for the
podcast
like some real ones man i'm excited as
[__]
it's you're just shaking your head no i
know it's getting real guys so thank you
so much for supporting because you guys
are really helping us out we've been
doing
this [__] out of pocket for a [__]
year just setting this up
i know it doesn't look like much but my
[__] broke
i'm broken [__] so having to pay for all
this [__] sucks dick
but it's wor it's worth it it's worth it
man so thank you guys so much for being
here
i'm thinking i'm gonna close it out
we're at two hours and 53 [__]
minutes guys thank you so much
if you sat through this whole thing i
appreciate you thank you
your weed man thanks you also because i
know you're burning through that [__]
sitting at home
if you're working or you're driving to
work and if you're commuting
and you listen to this move closer to
your [__] job
because if you're commuting three
[__] hours to work
you might be you might be ready
it makes no sense but i was thinking
was it the blue collar comedy tour yeah
what did ryan say ryan sickler
he said he said what do you mean you
don't have your accent out here why do
you use an american act or a regular
accent in the back
put your regular southern accent out
there that guy's [__] stupid
whoever thinks that that was a real
thing is [__]
stupid none of the cable guys funny as
[__] but that guy's
diehard fan to think that that's a we'll
just stop that yeah you guys heard the
[__] rhinesticker episode so you guys
know what i'm talking about
anyway that's it i think we're gonna
close it out
and this joint burning thank you guys so
much for hanging out
thank you for supporting check us out
google podcast apple podcast spotify
all streaming platforms just look up
dope as usual
if you got the [__] time leave
a review on spotify
it really helps man apple and apple too
i'm not sure if you can even leave
reviews on spotify i think i think you
can
i think i might be wrong you know what
oh you might i might be wrong but yeah
if you can't leave a review
thank you guys on apple i know we're
amazing and very much appreciated
appreciate you guys thank you so much
also check out our patreon the links are
always in the description
it's behind the scenes footage extra
stuff stuff you can't see anywhere
thank you guys so much for watching
thank you for supporting follow the dope
as usual clips channel that's also
linked in the description
thank you guys dopaziola.com looking
bomb as [__] new site thank you guys for
being on the new site
we appreciate you from drastic graphics
marty thank you so much for hanging out
with me for
[__] three hours thank you sir
appreciate it you guys we're gonna get
out of here
this has been another episode of the
dope as usual podcast the dopest podcast
in the world thank you very much
like i said um [__] why do i always do
that right when i'm closing down i go
oh
[Laughter]
maybe it could be the eighth but uh it's
okay it's okay
oh here we go [__] creep
here we go thank you so much for
watching the dope as usual podcast
dopest podcast in the world we
appreciate you guys from drastic
graphics marty thank you for watching
thank you guys so much i am dopaziola
have a dope ass day
trey
[Music]
nice three [__] hours
what's up guys that i know long as [__]
right that was a three hour episode if
you sat through that whole
thing and you're watching this right now
shout out to you thank you so much for
taking
three [__] hours out of your day to
watch that episode like i said earlier
shout out to stereo for allowing us to
be normal kids yeah i mean we're normal
we're not just trying to advertise
random weed companies which is fun i
love doing that but this is an actual
you know widely masked accepted app do
you see what i'm saying it's not just
hey check out this crystallized thc
which is the [__]
we can't do that on youtube so for our
um podcast channel
this is our first sponsor stereo do me a
favor go right now into the app store
download stereo it's free it takes you
five [__] seconds download it right
now while you're listening to it i don't
care
go download and follow us dope as usual
it's dope as usual on stereo app it is a
live chat
this is a live streaming app i'm going
to be able to stream more intimately
with you guys not just
because our pages are big it's rare that
i can
catch somebody and put their comment and
talk to them
do you see what i'm saying this is more
of do you want to talk to us directly
this is it this is the live chat like a
fun
20 person room i don't know how many
people are in there do you see what i'm
saying it's an up-and-coming app so it's
not like
there's thousands and thousands of
people on our page trying to get a hold
of us
this is more if you have a question you
wanted to ask on the podcast this is the
time
do me a favor go download stereo app on
the app store or whatever
[__] app store you got follow us dope
as usual thank you guys so much like i
said it's free and it really
really [__] helps us out so thank you
so much for watching have a dope ass day
[Music]
perfect